oh thank you you did
you you look like uh you you're well
rested like
the covid lockdown has done you well
thank you you know i
i i during this thing i came up with a
program
uh called the dial it back a little bit
program and it's like hey
except there's only six steps but you
don't get completely sober
so it's gonna be very popular i think
and uh
the first step was uh ron why don't you
quit drinking so [ __ ] much
and what is so [ __ ] much like what
what's the numbers ah
you know it's a half a bottle of tequila
a night or something like that maybe a
little more
uh wound back to a third by the way
these little cigars are the [ __ ]
these are really good romeo and julieta
tiny cigars yeah
that's the uh the mini cigarillo so
there's one that's a little bit bigger
than that
and it's called the cigarillo and these
are the minis and i started like i'm
saying it
when i was playing golf you know that
just whenever it's time for me to hit i
just throw it away and let another one
you know
there's 20 of them for 15 bucks so you
know as opposed to
a 15 cigar which is what i usually smoke
something like that and uh but it's good
tobacco
yeah it's really good it's the same
thing it's in their big old premium
cigars just wrote about rolled by the
junior rollers
that's how they learn and you look like
you're smoking a blunt
but we're clearly not
clearly and uh in austin what are you
saying about the rules
it's like a co would it you could have
as much as a quarter of a pound before
they arrest you
uh yeah a quarter of a pound is that
right
yeah uh and that and if you just say
it's
uh cbd cdb whatever nugs
then uh they would have to test it and
they don't want to test it they got
other things to do
so they have cbd stores out here folks
it's it's very strange
they have stores that sell cbd joints
but marijuana is illegal
right so i don't know you know my son is
in that business
and it it is confusing
the the uh and i think that's what helps
you know yeah is uh they got dizzy
trying to figure it out
but i was going through lax on the way
out here a week early
and uh because we set this up for uh
we were talking on friday and you said
next tuesday the 8th
well i don't even know what month it is
much less what day of the month it is
and so i just thought it's the next
tuesday coming up
which was only three days away and i was
a little mad at you and i was like going
wow it seems like you'd have given me
more than three days notice and i gotta
find a way to get to
l.a and i'm looking at flights there's
nothing good i'm thinking about bringing
my plane down
uh which it turns out has a problem so
we couldn't bring it down and
and uh and i get down here and he's like
the eighth
is uh a week from today and i was like
god i'm so stupid man we made it work
yeah we made it work
so they just plugged in this stuff a few
few days early and here i am
so you're not from here but you've been
here for how long now like two years
how long have you i've said you know i
started coming to austin when i was 15
years old
my my buddy his brother taught economics
at ut and had a house on 4th street
which at that time was just little bitty
low-end cracker box houses
but that mostly teachers lived in and he
would let us stay in his yard
and uh so we would tell my parents that
we were going camping at lake sutherland
and my buddy ricky bellows when he
turned 16
had the littlest new honda but he had
one that was wrecked and he rebuilt it
and we put all our camera gear in it and
come straight to austin
and uh set up in my uh brothers
my buddy mickey mcmillan his brother
scott mcmillan would set up in his yard
his backyard and then we'd walk two
blocks to sixth street
and it was probably 71 or 72
and austin was tripping balls
i mean it was people on unicycles in
clown suits
juggling backwards music pumping out of
every window
stevie ray vaughan coming out of this
with stevie ray vaughan on one end of
the guitar
and we're playing live live right just
out the window now we didn't have any
money and we couldn't get in any club so
we had we were completely broke
and but we were standing there listening
to this music watching this scene
of 6th street in 71 i guess it was about
71 or 2 when i've been 15
71. and uh and even then there were
people going
it's over you should have seen it in 67
i'm like
still still still looks pretty good to
me man
that's what some people always do though
oh yeah i missed it man
just the other day somebody was like oh
yeah it's just not what it used to be
and i'm like when'd you get here like
thursday
i'm like [ __ ] dude really it's taking a
dive since thursday
all these [ __ ] californians moving in
yeah they really hate that [ __ ]
yeah i talked to uh this guy's doing uh
it work he's like we're being invaded
right bro relax well
you know it's a i get it it's a great
state and
and uh but it's uh it's just a liberal
stronghold in the middle of a very
republican state and
you know i was born and raised here and
you know if people ask me if i'm a texan
i tell them i'm a texan you know this is
where i'm from and
and uh the state is uh slowly changing
and and becoming more palatable for
everybody and uh but there's still a
pretty hard right wing you know faction
that runs it all out of uh
out of dallas where all the money is in
houston and but that's what keeps it
from going haywire right right that's
what keeps it from going straight
portland
right yeah that's it you [ __ ] need
that man
those people are ridiculous you need
that you need you need law and order you
do
i don't i don't give a [ __ ] with anybody
yeah that's uh
my old joke was if you come to texas and
kill somebody we will kill you back
and go somewhere else and kill people
you'll be better off you know go to
california you know
it's just i just feel like you know
people want to
throw away everything that's there they
would just want to break it all down and
deconstruct
society but they don't really i mean
their plan
once they do that like you saw what
happened with uh that six block
chunk of seattle that they took over
jazz
it deteriorated almost instantly and
became a terribly run country
right they had borders they had people
beating people up for filming things
i mean they had murders they were
thinking about walls yes they took over
too not only that they
appropriated all the buildings they
didn't build those buildings they just
took it over
the problem with that kind of thinking
is even if you think you're right
you what you're doing now someone can do
that to you
because you've already shown that it can
be done you've already shown that you
could just
by force you can light the [ __ ] mayor
of portland's apartment building on fire
and stand out and chant well they can do
that to your house too right
you got to understand like what you're
doing is not nice
it's not civilized it's not polite this
is a civilized society
and if you decide you're going to do
things that are not civilized and you're
going to justify it
people can do things that are not
civilized to you like the founding
fathers as crazy as it is in the 1700s
figure this [ __ ] out in advance
they had a whole series of checks and
balances to keep things from going
sideways
they really had some good ideas it's
really amazing when you stop and think
about
their great insight into human nature
and how it could apply
and where it might go right they were
right they were right
yeah now you know when we were having
protests and
uh in vandalism or whatever in beverly
hills and they were saying that uh
the next uh you know they're coming to
tear your part
town apart you know i really didn't
think they would but i
still had a retired navy seal standing
in front of my house
uh with a gun and uh his message was
why don't you go [ __ ] up the house next
door ron and uh
and leave ron's place alone it's just
these young people
with these idealistic ideas about people
that are successful that somehow know
that you've stolen it from other people
and that you need to give it back to
everyone else we need to have a
communist society and it's like
where's the money coming from where
who's gonna work what are you gonna do
have you thought this through right you
know
i had always chosen the path of least
resistance
in my life and it just ended up here you
know in joe rogan's studio
at 63 years old this is the path of
least resistance this is where i ended
up
it is but it isn't you know you say that
but you you were a grinder you were out
there on the road
doing the hard gigs that's not the least
resistance
no it was you know it was so much fun i
couldn't stand it
you know i mean i would tap my foot when
i was at home i wanted to get back out
to the path of least resistance you know
because you know me i love stand-up
comedy and i love being on stage like
you do and uh
and uh and touring never bothered me you
know it got softer and softer
it started out it was 800 miles in a in
a nissan truck with a bench vinyl seat
that would bend you over the steering
wheel after 50 miles and you had 800
miles to go to atlanta
to do shows and i didn't care you know i
felt like i found it
yeah and and i didn't even know what it
was until i found it
the first time i was on stage i was like
oh i'm a comedian
that's what i am if you just look at
most of society at least i did when i
looked at most of society
most of what people were doing so
unappealing to me it just didn't
resonate with my mind and the way i grew
up it just didn't work
but as soon as i started doing comedy
going on the road i was like oh my god
i found this thing yeah i found a thing
that just works it just fits into my dna
it just it just makes sense that's the
same with me and i never
ever thought that my career would get as
big as it did
ever talking about divorce outside
you talked about how you've been [ __ ]
over and i said if i could just go back
in time when you were broke and i said
ron
in the year 2020 you will have been
[ __ ] out of
millions of dollars in divorce yeah and
you would be like
well [ __ ] man how much did i make how
did i get all that money
where'd it come from do i have any left
after this how am i doing so yeah and it
was it was two women
and uh and all together with lawyers and
all in for 10
probably 10 million bucks and ouch
and after tax money you know so that's
20 million in real world dollars
it's uh something like that uh
well you know if you're if you're making
dollars at the box office you know
you're
you're really only putting about 28
cents out of every dollar
in a bank account that you could spend
and so you got a big chunk going to
taxes and managers and
agents and travel and all that stuff and
you're trying to have fun
and trying to have a good time hey
you're not squirreling money away for
divorce
well it turns out it was i thought it
was retirement but uh
now it turns out you know i i really i
really believe that i'm retired i
believe i'm done
really you done with stand-up i think so
listen man we're going to open up a club
here in austin
oh i'll do that i'm going to drag you in
yeah you're going to crush
you're going to get that the feeling
down to your toes that tangle
whew i haven't even thought about a set
in a half a year
you know they they tapped on my bus and
uh the parking lot of a venue
uh in uh springfield uh illinois
and uh the parking lot was half full you
know i'd flown out from l.a got on my
tour bus
in uh in st louis my crew is with me
the crowd showing up they knock on the
door and said it's over
wow the government just uh the governor
just pulled the plug on this date and
then they plugged it on the next date
and i'm like [ __ ] there's not going to
be any shows till
may i bet
and boy was i wrong it's right now we're
in september
yes it is september and there's no shows
in sight well you can go some places
uh houston's doing shows san antonio's
doing shows
nashville's doing shows kansas city's
a lot of places like [ __ ] it let's roll
let's just do it yeah but you know the
you know zany's in nashville uh hugely
[ __ ] collapsed on stage there and he
had coveted and
the guy that ran the club uh got covered
from him
and he got it from hughley yeah from
ugly well he got it so we're assuming
it was for me maybe he gave it to him
well i could have gone the other way
except for ugly collapsed and then he
came up positive three days later
whoever hewgley's road manager is it
props to that guy because he saw it
coming and caught him
yeah right so yeah that's gonna hit the
floor i'm the [ __ ] cuz if he hits the
fall
floor man he's got brain damage right
yeah if you fall from that
you fall from a sitting position and
that's a kind of a high stage
yeah oh you've been there right yeah
yeah my manager would find out about it
on the internet the next day
he wouldn't not only would he not catch
me he wouldn't even know where i was
you know but it was a weird one right
did you watch the video
uh of him d.l uh like
his words got all jumbled together like
it did they didn't make sense yeah no i
didn't see it
and then there was one it was it was
very strange like and the crowd was like
what
what the [ __ ] did he just say comedy
oh is that it what are you doing jamie
why is it not going where it's supposed
to be
we got a lot of [ __ ] technical
glitches we're working out the gremlins
here right now
at the new studio jamie's trying to show
it for us he'll show it to us
we'll get it we'll figure it out but it
was a weird moment where
he uh he just paused and then
and just started collapsing his manager
caught him right in time and then he
just dragged him off the stage
oh i'd like to see the footage of that
yeah we would uh
we would you know i play golf when i'm
there at the same course
there it is let's see if we can hear it
i can't i got that's what i was working
on
see he catches him look at this
right though oh it still bounced his
head though
it wasn't a great catch no it wasn't the
best catch
i like that little gray goatee thing
going on like that yeah if i
like it so much i grew one i played golf
with him uh
him and uh cedric and george lopez
a few months ago that must have been a
fun outing yeah i was staying at this
bakar resort up in santa barbara and i
just looked across the bar and it was
hugely and cedric
sitting there and i'm like who is that i
recognize these guys and uh
and i went over and started i just heard
them order tequila and i was like
oh this is kindred spirits over here i'm
gonna upgrade their order because they
sold my tequila at that place and uh so
i sent them over some tequila and i'm
like
and and they threw a fit over me you're
ron
why brother white and i'd worked with
cedric he middle for me on the road and
i knew he was going to be a star then as
they're stopping this guy you know he's
got so much talent and energy and
uh so it turns out lopez was coming up
to play golf with him the next day you
know so we
we hooked up made it a foursome killed a
bottle of uh of a number one extra yajo
on the course we
passed it around on the 18th to polish
it off and
and uh what a what a hoot you know what
a glorious day that was
and just laughter and fun and i'm sure
golf is awesome it's just
that's a lot of time it's a time you
don't have time for it buddy
i don't have time you ain't got time for
it i don't know how you do what you do
three shows a day or two three of these
a day and then
everybody i don't think anymore well you
the last time i did your show
i was the third one that day and and uh
you're like yeah i'm gonna go do my abs
and then i got five sets tonight and i'm
like jesus christ
i'm gonna go to bed i was drunk stoned
i'm like you're gonna do what yeah yeah
i gotta do my abs and i'm gonna head on
over
yeah last podcast we did we got a little
lit yeah we got crazy
yeah early so it's your [ __ ] tequila
you come bringing your own tequila
what's a man supposed to do right you
gotta drink it you gotta drink it so you
were saying you're just in the
in the tequila business now you're
basically not even in the comedy
business anymore you know i
actually told somebody in a conversation
that that i used to be a comedian
i say they said what do you do i used to
be a comic and then i kind of caught
myself i'm like well
because i believe if you want to be a
comedian all you have to do is go be a
comedian but you have to do that
right you have to go do it you have to
go do shows and all those things and
that i just don't do anymore when you
call someone a comic
like how how long they have to have done
it
you know before i recognize it
uh a while you know what's a while you
know
i i think you start i'd say five
five years yeah before you start to even
start to understand the relationship
between you and all those people out
there
uh it's a it's a long process i think i
caught it on i
i caught on to do and stand up really
quickly so when i had four minutes
i could kill for four minutes and then i
could kill for five minutes so i
always kind of understood how to
generate the power
you know even from pretty early on uh
but i still only had five minutes
uh i think the worst thing that can
happen to a young comic now is they come
out and win some contest and all of a
sudden they were headlining but
you know they won with 10 minutes of
material and then what do you do
that's a that's a tough spot to be in
yeah it's horrible charlie murphy was
famous and then he started doing
stand-up so he was doing stand-up as a
famous person
famous for being funny on the chappelle
show right
that took balls yeah i did and i i was
around charlie during those days and it
was crazy i mean he just
was learning stand-up in front of
sold-out crowds
that's scary but i never thought any of
this even though i was standing right
next to foxworthy when he exploded
uh into one of the biggest comics that
ever lived
uh i never thought it would happen to me
you know i just didn't uh
and i was okay with it you know i liked
being a club headliner and i was
i was still making you know as much
money as my friends
or more as a club headliner and and i
wasn't paying my taxes which made it
seem like i made even more money
all right so i'm picking up tabs and
[ __ ] right and
uh but i never saw a big you know big
big success uh ever coming my way
and it just did i think the most the
most fun you have
is when you're just making enough money
to not worry about money
everything else gets it gets complicated
yeah
things get complicated when they can
take 10 million from you in a divorce
yeah right that is
well you know what that's the thing i
remember when uh
after blue collar came out and all of a
sudden
when the dvd came out all of a sudden i
could sell out any
venue in the country in two minutes
literally
and the money was coming in and i was so
joyous because i didn't see what else
was coming behind it
right i just saw all of a sudden i'm
making money hand over fist over hand
over
fist and i'd wake up in the morning glad
to be
me you know i would wake up going yeah
this is great
i could go online and look i'm a
millionaire look at this i'm a
millionaire
this is the most fantastic thing ever
but i didn't see
what was coming you know just as far as
all the you know i'm
basically an idiot and and uh or
i'm a fool in his money and you don't
want to walk away from that
without a big pile of it and uh
you know it didn't it yeah and i'm kind
of getting to a place in my life where
now i'm like all right i'm okay i'm okay
i still i've still got it
i mean i still have the finances to
retire comfortably and
i mean not i actually
i was my girlfriend lives on a main
channel over on
oxnard at the marina and we were talking
about
getting a boat so i called my friend
who's an offshore boat racer and a
billionaire
and and uh i said i just want you know
he knows a lot about boats he'd give
maybe give us some direction on what
kind of boat would be great and
so he started asking me right away on
the phone call he
said how's the career going man what's
going on in your life i said it's over
man i don't have any dates i have
nothing on the books i don't know when
it's coming back
and i talked to my financial people and
said let's figure that i'm never going
to make another dime what can i keep
what can i what do i sell and
and i said i got to get rid of the plane
and probably the bus and he goes well at
least you don't have a boat
and i was like oh that was the next that
was my next question man i was going to
sell the boat to get a
on the bus to get a boat do you but if
everything comes back like if if they
develop a vaccine
if we reach herd immunity if people
start touring again
you'll be out there come on man i don't
know come on man
i don't know what's left oh man i'll
bring you out there i'll just bring you
out for a guest set
all right bring you out for a little
guess i'll give you a little taste you
know i feel the roar of the crowd ladies
and gentlemen please welcome
ron white yeah wouldn't it be nice
i you know i i could tell because i
always worked really hard right and
uh i'm not worked really hard but i
always did a lot of shows
right uh toured all the time and
if i took 10 days off i could feel it in
my big set
yeah you know just that information's
not floating as close to the top as i'd
like for it to be
and and then by the next set it was a
little better but third set i'm fine and
i haven't done a set thought about a set
looked at a set list watched the tape in
a half a year
and i don't know what i've i don't know
how long it would even take to get it
back
or if it or if i could just walk back
into it you'd walk right back into it
i did uh houston improv i guess about a
month and a half two months ago now
and um i uh listened to a bunch of sets
and uh i did the whole weekend and the
the fir i listened to like three or four
recordings
made notes wrote down all my stuff i
forgot a couple of things forgot the way
the order or a few taglines but
i walked out just having a great time i
had a great time first show was a little
odd like wow can't believe i'm doing
stand-up again
by the second show was a show by the
third show i was back
okay but it was just because i listened
to all the recordings i took a lot of
time
i really went over it what venue what
size venue were you it's a small place
the improv
okay you know i mean i think it seats
500 and i think they they were at 75
capacity yeah right not really yeah why
are there no empty chairs
that's pretty packed oh we took the
chairs we didn't need outside but it was
a good time
it was it was fun but then i started
thinking man what if i got it and then
gave it to somebody
that's my word worry i give it to some
person that has a compromised immune
system
right well that's what you know i was
telling you that my girlfriend and i
i was gonna move uh this
i bought a new car for out in l.a and i
wanted to move the car that was out
there
out here so we decided to just drive it
so we stopped in
vegas and stayed
at the bellagio when i i've always
worked at the mirage and i found out
that outside the mirage i'm nobody
even with the mgm grand folks and so it
was kind of just you know
a week before we got there people were
going who's got the keys to this thing
man how do you turn those lights on
oh right we fired those people uh we got
to get them back because we don't know
how to do this
yeah those casinos had basically shut
down for months at a time yeah and they
load everybody and those are monster
complicated [ __ ] properties
and then we went to uh we had we
did some gambling we ate some decent
food and no shows or anything and
we were there for three days and it was
great played golf and
and uh but we just stayed to ourselves
and we won some money playing blackjack
and went
uh spent it immediately on caviar and
champagne and
uh i'm like look what we want this is
great
and we went to sedona
and sedona's you've been to sedona
arizona just
like hippie land yeah it's all crystals
just beautiful it is beautiful oh it's
like stunning
i mean every direction you look why does
it attract so many flaky people though
they say it's because of some kind of a
vibe
that it has energy or whatever yeah
and uh we're staying in this you know
it's kind of a five-star resort and it
was down on this river with these little
cabins and this beautiful
river wolf whatever oak creek or
whatever it is and cuts through these
huge canyons and
and uh you could take these adirondack
chairs and put them in the river and
just sit in this beautiful clear running
river with
it and just sit out there and relax and
let the world go by and breathe and it
was really really nice
and uh i told jeannie i said you know
what we could do
because we had our we were made kind of
last-minute reservations so we had the
littlest cabin furthest from the river
but there was a little house right on
the river i don't know what they charged
for it but it was cool as [ __ ]
and i said you know what we could do we
would pool our money
and just rent this place and we'll just
live here
until we're broke until it's all or
there's all the money's gone we've run
up a tab we can't pay it we just
i'll tell them there's money coming
we've already spent millions here
and then when the cops are wading into
the river
to drag us out and throw us off the
property we'll shoot ourselves
and just float dead and she was like
what
i'm not saying i'm not saying we have to
i'm just saying and then i kind of
okay with a syringe of heroin and just
but whatever you know that uh
she next it yeah yeah chicks don't like
those romantic ideas
yeah so then we went to santa fe then
austin and then i had my tour bus pick
us up in austin and took us to
up to uh nashville and then to see my
mother
in uh in cocoa beach florida and uh
so we had cobot tests before we got to
mother's house
to to you know make sure even though
we'd been being very very safe that uh
you know i couldn't
bear the thought of uh yeah off and my
mom
and uh yeah that's the big fear man
that's the big fear the big fear is
giving it to somebody who can't handle
it right
right it's um it's a weird one man i
mean the this uh
society has changed in such a radical
way over the last six months it's almost
like
if you well i know someone who actually
did get hit by a car
right right before george floyd died
and had brain damage and came out of a
coma
like while the riots were going on like
literally didn't know what was going on
and has brain damage
and he's trying to put it all together
like you ever see that movie 28 days
later
yeah awesome zombie movie but the guy
wakes up in the middle of a coma
from a coma and the world's changed he
woke up and there a virus that swept
through the land
some a virus that they created for
chimpanzees
called rage and it escaped from a lab
and started infecting people
and turned them into these wild zombie
creatures
right but you know it's almost like that
like this
person that i know woke up from this
from getting hit by a car flown through
the air
landed on their head got all [ __ ] up
in a coma for 10 days hospitalized and
then coming out of it
watching the news going what the [ __ ] is
happening right
this cops car's on fire streets are
burning
people wearing masks everyone's wearing
a mask and uh
and not wearing masks you know i was so
protective of my mom but she wants to
get out she wants to go to the grocery
store
she wants to go you know but she's just
been locked up so
she she she also cooks for me
you know she my mother loves to cook for
me and and it was almost like
breaking bad when they chained that guy
to the meth lab that's what my mother
looked like in the kitchen you know just
making fried chicken and fried shrimp
and gumbo and all the things i love and
but we went to the store and you know
she likes to you know she doesn't walk
that stable but so she likes to walk
with a you know with his cart and so we
went and
there were people not wearing masks and
i just wanted to
[ __ ] cuss them out you know and uh
you know so that that so they get to
walk around with no mask i got to keep
my mother in a
storage facility you know so she doesn't
catch this disease and
so i'd like for everybody to catch on
with the mass thing you know and just
let's let's get through this yeah i
think most people have caught on with it
now
don't you think most people are wearing
masks it's pretty rare that people
aren't wearing masks especially around
old folks it's become i think a little
bit better and we're you know we're
getting some better numbers right now so
that's good
you know that's uh i i hope
you taking your vitamin d no okay
well you got to take vitamin d it's very
important there was an article that was
just published recently that i put on my
twitter page
um that i don't read your twitter page
but you don't have to but i'll send you
the things directly that are important
all right but uh this was uh talking
about vitamin c
and people that get covid and wind up in
the icu
and vitamin vitamin d rather vitamin d
seems to be the
the biggest factor that people um one of
the things
dr rhonda patrick talked about on the
podcast too is that more than 80 percent
of the people in the icu are deficient
in vitamin d
and only four percent had sufficient
levels of vitamin d
the vitamin d has a significant impact
on your immune system and most people
don't
get it you probably get a good amount
because you're out in the sun golfing a
lot
but probably not quite enough right and
you should almost always supplement
yeah i might you know my doctor said
something i just had all my tests done
the other day and
and uh he said that you need to boost
your uh
vitamin d that's what he said everybody
does right humans aren't supposed to
live in this little [ __ ] red
spaceship we're supposed to be outside
in the world
i mean this is how we evolved we evolved
to be outside all the time
we didn't evolve to be indoor creatures
so our bodies are designed to absorb
vitamin d from the sun i mean that's
that's how we create vitamin d in our
body right and i think you're right i do
i do spend an awful lot of time outside
so
that but you know i need to get on a
program that's for sure
you know are you willing i'll put you on
a program i'm willing i'm willing to be
on a program
yeah now do you take a ton of vitamins i
take a lot of [ __ ]
even though and you believe it's all
good
yeah i feel great you have more energy
than anybody i know
do you sleep at all i do that's one of
the reasons why i have energy
i sleep a lot a little amount of sleep
for me is six hours that's a little
amount like that's like a oh i gotta
catch up
a good night i'm sleeping eight maybe
even nine
yeah i sleep i sleep good
it's important yeah everything man it's
everything that's uh you know that's uh
that's what i want from you you
know i i'd love to have joe rogan energy
instead of ron white energy
which is uh uh man let's take a nap
that's the tequila son
oh no that's uh that's salvation that's
uh
pour some of that salvation all right
all right crack it open
i was gonna i was gonna make this deal
that uh that for sure i didn't drink for
the first hour
i think we're about 40 minutes okay
that's close good enough yeah
close close enough 30 minutes because
you made yourself a deal that's
hilarious
yeah see if you drink this every day
you're not gonna have a lot of energy
but you will have
an interesting energy while you're
drinking it you know it's just
it's a treat it's a stimulant and i know
i've told you that before instead of a
depressant cheers joe rogan here's my
brother
congratulations to both of us thank you
for everything for everything
um
some good ideas with this stuff this
stuff will bring me to some strange
places
it will sure i was also going to bring
some shrooms but i decided not to
are you uh still microdosing you know it
did it stop working no it didn't stop
working out the the guy i was getting it
from went to
prison and uh so for mushrooms
i don't know what are the odds yeah
right i don't know yeah
i think that's exactly what happened who
the [ __ ] is putting someone in jail
for mushrooms that guy should go to jail
yeah it's you know
he was a door guy in a club and uh
but he was really doing it because
you know he knew a lot of vets that had
you know ptsd and
and they and people were feeling like
hallucinogens were you know making a
connection for some of these guys and
particularly micro dosing yeah microdose
and that's what and that's what i was
doing unless there was a concert to go
to and then i was
maxo dosing well i ran into you at the
green room at the comedy store
and you're like i found this thing
that's [ __ ] amazing
i'm just micro dosing yeah i guess i'm
on medication puts a little sparkle in
yeah
your day and and uh so you know and i
still you described it as wonderful
wonderful how are you feeling it's
wonderful it's
wonderful take the drugs and go to the
concert you know
have fun you know just get my lazy ass
but the microdosing
is it's like it's just enough to feel it
right
it's just like you just just enough to
feel it
you just just enough to take the edge
off of life
yes but you're very there very coherent
yeah even more
probably yeah well they say you see
things better
there was studies done on visual acuity
one of these uh
psychedelic researchers they did these
things with people they gave them low
doses of psilocybin and they they were
able to detect uh movement
quicker than people without it like so
they have two lines two parallel lines
and when one of the lines would diverge
off of parallel the people on mushrooms
could recognize it much quicker
than the people not on mushrooms yeah
you know at one of my earliest mushroom
experiences
uh maybe the first
we had we'd heard about it of course i
was in houston so mushrooms were at the
end of every street because it's all
developed ranch land the further you out
you go
so at the end of it there's a pasture
and that's full of mushrooms
right i had no idea had they had value
anywhere because they were just so
readily available
and when we were i'd boiled some up
and uh me and joe payne and uh
and we drank them but we didn't know how
long it took for it to hit and then joe
had to leave and i'm sitting there and
my dad comes home i was staying with him
and
uh and i feel these mushrooms coming on
a little bit
and then there was this horrible wreck
in houston where this
big truck was some kind of gas flipped
on one of those big overpasses and they
had cameras out there
and i started laughing so hard it was
the funniest thing i
ever seen and uh and i couldn't stop
myself from laughing at it and it wasn't
funny at all
and it but it just the laughter was in
my dad i remember him just looking at me
going what's wrong with him
and uh so i left and i was driving my
car and i noticed that i could see an
eye of a bird that was 50 yards away
while i was running into the back of
another car
so i'm i can't really i can't really
uh verify that everything but the birds
eye was looking at and then all of a
sudden
not very hard but it was definitely a
wreck
yeah it makes you see things makes you
hear things
makes you you hear yeah speaking of here
comes and goes we got some gremlins
spaceship noises
where spaceships say looking plays here
yeah we're working this place out trying
to figure it out
i like it though i think it's it you
know
whenever you're in a new spot you got to
get accustomed to it still feels weird
like we did one with adam curry it just
it felt weird it just feels weird to be
here
yeah i'm already used to it yeah i'm
used to i'm used to austin
tell you that i got used to it quick i'm
settled in
i love it i like it a lot i love the
less people
i love how friendly everybody is there's
a lot a lot of good things about this
place
i love the barbecue i had diarrhea for
four days in a row i couldn't stop
really i was eating his [ __ ] barbecue
i had like a piece of lettuce
in four days it was all ribs ribs and
sauce
like jesus where are they coming from
where you got a go-to place or you oh
man i was going everywhere
um i i found this hole in the wall um a
bee cave barbecue holy [ __ ] it's like a
trailer
like this little trailer that you pull
up to
[ __ ] phenomenal you know they're all
born out of this phenomenal
this uh you know these are all sorts you
know early uh
german settlements through uh new
braunfels and they just understood smoke
houses and is that what it is that's
where it all came from
wow it all came from germany yeah no
kidding yeah
ah wow well i know there's a lot of
german folks that live in fredericksburg
right
like out there oh and uh wineries new
braunfels and what's
south of new braunfels uh uh where did
your aunt live
and oh they live in new braunfels uh
what's
but anyway that's where that was all
german settlements and
we used to go camp and we'd go tube the
guadalupe river which is a
fun fun thing to do and we stayed at a
campground called the lazy l
l and it which used to be a farm for
this german family and the guy that
owned it
figured out he could turn it into a
campground and make easy easier money so
he did
he was about 90 years old and he smelled
horrible
just really stunk always always wearing
the same clothes
he told me he wanted to show me
something so their old barns were there
and stuff and he took me over and he
showed me
a plow that had a seat on it
and he said that when he saw that he as
he said that he thought everything that
could be invented had been invented
now you're sitting on a plow are you
[ __ ] kidding me living the good life
living the goddamn the horse is dragging
you
and the plow you're all good and uh
you're not doing anything your boots
aren't getting muddy
no i don't know you're above it you're
good you're above it
through life living that silver star
life
that's a um it's a weird thing that the
immigrants
came out here learning how to smoke meat
like german smoked meat and smoked
sausages and they
somehow another morphed that into
barbecue it was everybody that worked
for that one of those
people they went and started their own
place because they learned how to do it
and it just kind of spread from that
and uh you can't have bad barbecue here
you will not survive
no no no no no you will not survive i
found that out everyone
you cannot make any money selling shitty
barbecue in the texas hill country
you cannot no it's not happening
yeah everything's good yeah
the the real worry like i was saying is
uh that people like me will come here
and [ __ ] it up how could you [ __ ] i'm
not gonna [ __ ] it up i'm gonna find
nice texas people and say tell me how to
vote i'll vote your way
i want i want to keep your thing going
whatever you did
to get this like i want to keep this
going it had nothing to do with politics
no
it didn't it didn't but politics could
[ __ ] it up though
not the barbecue no not the barbecue but
they could [ __ ] up some of the aspects
of this place like
yeah the freedom parts right yeah the
thing the thing about
having a place like this is you gotta
kind of let people do like one of the
things that i love about texas
is the fact that it's so wild that you
could do
a lot of [ __ ] here you could do crazy
like i looked at a ranch
and i said what if i wanted to put a
comedy club on this ranch
is there any rules they go no no go
ahead they were like go ahead i go what
about a shooting range they're like oh
yeah of course
fine yeah bring it like do whatever the
[ __ ] you want put a fence around shoot
every animal you have
yeah it's freedom
it is it is it's freedom yeah and uh
i i i enjoy you know i'm uh socially
uh pretty liberal but physically pretty
conservative and
yeah me too uh so i uh
you know and you know i i just lean that
way and so i
i hope that texas you know leans that
way
too you know i don't know that it ever
will but
you know i i i love the
the freedom of texas and uh and and i
love calling myself a texan you know
it's
it was a sovereign nation at one time we
could fly our flag as high as the u.s
flag no other state can because they
weren't
a sovereign nation that's true you you
could fly the texas flag
it's the only flag yep yep do you know
why
uh this place is so crazy do you know
the whole history why it's so different
than anywhere else
why austin or texas just texas in
general because it was its own country
because the comanches uh the comanches
that's really what it is
okay we had all right let's hear it joe
they had to fight off the comanches
the comanches they were mean were the
baddest [ __ ] in the plains
and they literally ran the western part
of this country
they were the most savage they they all
they ate was meat
they lived off of like buffalo meat
basically they learned how to ride
horseback better than any other indians
they learned how and they call
themselves indians this is a thing like
native american versus indian i've
talked to them
they prefer the term indian i don't i
don't know if that
applies to all of them but the ones that
i've talked to when i've been trying to
educate myself about this [ __ ]
they said we we prefer the term indians
but didn't the american people or the
the settlers call them indians because
they thought we were they were in india
the original people in the 1400s thought
they were in india yeah but for whatever
reason
it stuck and but the comanches they were
when the the the texas rangers were the
first guys to figure out how to beat the
comanches
so mexico was allowing people to move in
to texas and oklahoma back in the day
when the settlers are
like go ahead my friend go ahead it's
free and they were basically using
settlers as a buffer for the comanches
because everybody who moved into these
places and built houses just got
slaughtered
right and so when the but it was rangers
mexico until when yes until what year i
don't remember what year
but they figured out the texas rangers
were the first guys who figured out how
to fight the comanche
and that what they did is they basically
fought like them the early settlers used
to get off of their horses to shoot
so they get off their horses with a
[ __ ] musket and the comanches would
run on them and they could shoot five
six arrows in six seconds so they would
just
boom filling them up with arrows and
these poor bastards had the musket with
the stick and the powder and they got
[ __ ]
so colt figured out how to make a
revolver
and the first revolver was made like
somewhere in like the 1840s
and one of the very first people that
used the revolver
was the texas rangers was jack hayes
jack hayes was the original texas ranger
and this bad [ __ ]
figured out how to live like a comanche
fight off a horseback
99 sure that's his name jack hayes
google that real quick
but um we have a we actually made a a
large
photo of this dude that's gonna hang in
the the front lobby
oh cool yeah there he is john hayes
well they call him jack too right isn't
that weird that jack is a nickname for
john
yeah john f kennedy is jack kennedy yeah
that doesn't make any sense how the [ __ ]
did that happen
jack hayes yeah john coffey jack hayes
was an american military officer so that
dude he's there's a large
metal photo that's being made of him
he's the reason why texas exists
because these these [ __ ]
figured out how to fight the comanches
they figured out how to do it and partly
because of colt and because of the
revolver
and the revolver was basically this all
comes from a book that's an amazing book
that i read uh called empire the summer
moon by this uh this guy
uh sam gwen s s g gwen
and it's all about the comanches and
and how difficult it was for the
settlers to make it across
texas so texas became this fiercely
independent place partially in part
because of their
battles with the comanches who ran
through austin is there
like you can find comanche arrowheads in
austin
still to this day i have friends who've
found them here right i have friends
that look for them all the time
foxworthy is one of them he goes on
these arrowhead searches all over the
place and where they find them for the
most is those uh buffalo jumps
you know those places where the command
she would force buffalo off cliffs
i didn't even know that this is how wild
it is they would force so many of them
off of cliffs that they would rot in a
pile because they couldn't eat all of
them
they would rot in a pile and there would
be so much bacteria
and rot that they would spontaneously
combust
so most of these buffalo jumps like when
you would find at the bottom of
they'd be charred like charred cliffside
because the piles of buffalo would would
literally
burst and burst into flames
how do you know all this stuff joe i
smoke a lot of weed
i smoke weed and i get into things
that's why i can't play golf i know i
know you don't have time for golf well i
can't play golf because i'd get obsessed
yeah you would that's the problem
like jiu-jitsu or whatever it is you
know and i would get obsessed yeah
i know i would i tony hinchcliffe is
obsessed now that poor bastard
he's hooked he plays golf every day
sends me pictures i know he's telling me
i just played
golf with uh uh or just had a
conversation with a guy named pete that
we all know that uh oh yeah
and uh and he had just played golf that
morning with hinchcliffe and he said
he's
he's horrible but he's so into it that
it it doesn't even matter that's how he
is with pool
yeah hinchcliffe is horrible at a lot of
things that he's really into
yeah i think he's uh i think he's really
funny though
oh he's one of the best up-and-coming
comics in america
he came with me to houston when we did
that gig yeah
yeah he's [ __ ] hilarious he's talking
about moving to austin he's kind of
i'm dragging him on here on white he
said there's going to be no place to do
stand-up and i'm like no there is
there is joe's going to open a club man
i'm going to open up a club 100
that's the plan there's a long-term plan
there's a ranch and a club in those
wrong
long-term plans and the club's going to
be on the ranch i don't know yet i
haven't decided yet
oh no you got to have a club where
people can go to it yeah yeah they get
in a car
they go to the ranch no no no
you might be wrong i could not be wrong
about this you might be wrong
location location location i don't know
i don't know about that not
barbecue yeah not just barbecue and
comedy i mean like outdoor festivals i
want to put in an amphitheater and do
charity concerts oh wow like
legitimately yeah i think it all can be
done promote it on the podcast
but just have it for for good for good
will all the money goes to charity i
forget about
your platform and how many people it
reaches i know the first time i did your
uh podcast i had no idea how big it was
you just asked me to come do it and i
was
driving down there going i can't believe
i said i would do this and i had no idea
and then i [ __ ] hit a curb while i
was pulling in and busted a tire and i'm
like god damn it
and then it turns out it was the biggest
thing i've ever done in my career was
your podcast
more people saw that than anything and i
got more people coming up to me i saw
you on rogue and i saw you on rogan i'm
sorry on rogan i'm like god damn how
many people are watching this [ __ ]
thing i remember you grabbed me at the
comedy store afterwards you i had no
[ __ ] idea
no idea no idea nobody told me you know
you didn't tell me
you just i just knew you had a podcast
and uh turned out you know turned out to
be a hell of a gig well the thing is it
seems like it's not
right because it's just you and me here
hanging out you know
it seems like it's it seems seems like
it's just us
yeah right sure this is how we would do
if we were the back bar of the comedy
store exactly the same thing
and that's why when i watch it you know
i watched one
the other day with you and whitney
cummings and annie letterman yeah and
that was really good those girls were
awesome oh they were so funny
those girls are so funny did i tell you
about uh about uh
whitney's pig yes she drove it all the
way to texas to a [ __ ]
pig sanctuary and i made it did you meet
it
yeah you got pictures oh yeah yeah
to the big sanctuary so what happened
was we were gonna do
i was talking to j mcgraw and we were
thinking about doing uh
uh jay's moving down here huh jay's
moving out here i know you know i don't
believe it
you already bought a house oh he didn't
tell me that yeah got a house online oh
no he did tell me that on travis right
[ __ ]
yeah so all right we're bringing them
all out here
all right come on come on bang the drums
put up the bat signal
yeah i told somebody the other day that
uh he said why is uh
why is rogan moving out here and i said
well because i moved
out here and you started crying like
what am i going to do with that run why
i'm like just come on out here joe and
it'll be great
well you did say that you did say that
and i wiped a tear from your eye with a
little tissue and
and then you just use that bandana you
have wrapped around your neck right
just to just to dry your tears and tell
you there's hope
for your future yeah but you were
talking about in glowing terms and
that's not a small part of why i'm here
there's
several people that talked about it in
such glowing terms
and when the looting hit that was the
big wake-up call for me i was like
okay yeah i see what's going on here you
know i either can have
you know armed guards everywhere which i
already had you know at the studio
or you know and but it felt weird felt
on
la feels unmanageable it feels like it's
out of control and that
garcetti guy is not handling it well no
i don't think so no it's a [ __ ]
disaster and there's more tents now than
i've ever
seen in any rei convention everywhere
you go everyone's camping
you know it's like the streets are
filled with people that got evicted from
their houses or
lost their jobs or don't have any money
for anything and it's just
it's just way too many folks way too
many folks and
not enough people working and it just
seems dangerous right
well it's the climate's so good that if
i was gonna be
you know if if i had no home
i would want to live in southern
california and be homeless there
yeah guys who haven't made is those
mobile home dudes that drive around
those shitty mobile houses
right because i mean basically you park
it and there's your house i mean you got
a roof you got it until they make you
move then you move and
park it there yeah but i mean they're
not even making people move that much
anymore after covet everything
after this whole george floyd thing and
the attacks on the police officers like
there's very few things they're
enforcing that they used to enforce they
used to kick the where
our old studio was they used to kick
them off the streets
they should not let them park on the
street now they're all over the streets
you'll go down one of the side streets
in the valley and you'll see
15 in the van nuys area you'll see like
15 of them in a row
20 in a row there's basically villages
of people that are living out of their
mobile homes
and most of them they barely can drive
you know there's a lot of them right
he's all [ __ ] up right we thought
someone was shooting
in front of our house we thought guns
were going out in front of the studio
rather and uh
the security guys go out there and it's
just one of those guys trying to start
up his truck
it was backfiring bang bang bang i mean
really loud like we were like oh [ __ ]
it's going down
right out front but no just a dude
trying to move
yeah yeah yeah i figured when i needed
to felt like i needed to hire
uh an armed guard to protect my home
there which turned out you know wouldn't
probably didn't yeah probably didn't
matter
but i was that worried about it you know
just that uh
yeah i'm gonna go ahead and put somebody
up there you know and i felt kind of you
know odd about doing that but
uh because i figured if somebody paid me
to guard their house once people started
coming at me i would just find another
job
right i would move on down the road and
do something else for a living you need
more than one guy
right well there were actually two
because my manager lives on that street
too so he had one and i had one
and uh but they never got it you know
it's pretty high up there
uh so they just never got that high you
know it was down in the flats there were
some problems the thing is
once things start happening and you you
didn't start it but you're doing it
like you're like looting like it's it
takes a lot to get people to smash
get someone to smash a window and run
into into a store and steal things it
takes a lot
but once someone smashed the window and
there's three people in there stealing
things
it's not that hard to run in there right
that's what the problem with my
mentality is once things start happening
it seems getting this butt head momentum
going yeah and you can't [ __ ] stop it
yeah it's very hard to stop and
once the genies out of the bottle like
it is in la when they when they let
those cop cars on fire and smash all
those streets on melrose and all the way
down to hollywood boulevard and
just robbed all those stores i was like
oh you're not doing anything about this
there's no no cops are stopping this
you're gonna let them the strategy was
to let them burn themselves out
right i'm like well you've just set a
precedent right and it's going to take
years to turn this [ __ ] battleship i
heard immunity is kind of what they were
going for there
eventually it'll all be okay yeah
i wish you know i was shocked i've been
i've been in a state of shock
you know and and and somewhat depressed
uh about the state of the nation you
know and uh and the world that we live
in and how
what's the answer to all this you know
is there an answer to all this
and and it has affected me emotionally
and
and uh and not just certainly not
because of what's happened to
to me it's just my fear of what's
happening to everybody else because i
know i'm okay
right and uh and i'm in a in
a in a great uh a great position to
weather the storm but that's one of the
reasons why you're okay
the the people the the real danger is
when
the economic situation deteriorates into
a place where it's unmanageable and that
that's how it is for a lot of people a
lot of those people that are looting and
robbing stores like
aoc something said something ridiculous
like maybe those people just stealing
some bread
to feed their families like probably not
but
the reason why they're doing it is
because they're broke that's
there's no rich people out there looting
you know they're looting because they're
desperate and because
covid in the lockdown has put people
into this unmanageable situation where
they really don't have any light at the
end of the tunnel they don't know what
to do
that's dangerous and so that's where you
realize how much economic prosperity is
attached to a civilized society
if everybody's doing well everybody's
fine but as soon as people aren't doing
well
right more is more danger there's more
crime there's more
you know and i don't know how that turns
around
when all these businesses go under and
then people have what are they going to
start new businesses
yeah like how much going on just the
number of restaurants that we lost in
austin that'll never come back and small
but not just restaurants that's the one
i feel because i
go out to eat every meal but but
i know that these mom and pop shops were
not prepared for this
and uh in any way shape or form and uh
they hung on for a minute and they're
gone
yeah and uh and will they ever come back
you know
but god you know you hope so yeah but
you wonder how
you know you wonder how well austin at
least they're letting these people stay
open with limited capacity and you know
make people wear masks
in la you can't do anything i mean la's
the one place in the whole country where
you can't
open a beauty salon you can't there's
all these hairdressers and barber shops
are [ __ ] right they've been closed for
six months you see that nancy pelosi
[ __ ]
did you see that that did how [ __ ]
crazy is that lady
she she without a mat without wearing a
mask i mean you want to talk about a
hypocrite
the the [ __ ] all the beauty salons
are locked down
she went into the beauty salon with no
mask wandering around
got a blowout when no one else could
even go to the beauty salon
they caught her on security camera they
uploaded it and you know what she said
it's a set up she she said it was a
setup right like they set her up
like you know the [ __ ] i don't even
have any hair
right and i know you can't go to a
beauty salon
i mean it doesn't apply to you joe
literally literally doesn't apply to me
at all
and i know the [ __ ] rules she's the
speaker of the house you're telling me
you don't know the rules in your
district in san francisco
you don't know the rules of course you
know the rules of course you do that's
so
slippery that lady handed trump a giant
gift
oh yeah it was almost like when uh
when uh hillary called the supporters a
basket of deplorables i'm like you just
handed a man that had a baton a bat to
hit you with and not a regular one
stupid and then the ones
with the barbed wire wrapped around it
like a dude had it oh bloody weapon
yeah the minute i heard that i was like
oh god yeah
i thought you're supposed to be smart
she's not smart she's just a politician
she's just greasy they've just been
doing it long enough so they know the
the moves to do and the right steps it's
like
yeah they're all gross it's there's no
getting around it you can't you can't
survive in that business if you're
if you're not gross right you just
that's how you get there that's how you
stay there
and they they they feed off of the fact
that they have control
they feed off of the fact they have
power over other people they have more
power than anyone else and that's
one of the reasons why she would do
something like that you tell me she
can't get someone to come to her house
and wear a mask and give her a blowout
she's worth a hundred million dollars of
course she can do that right but she's
like
i'm gonna white gradient mirror and
they're gonna do it for me
i'm not gonna wear a mask right i've
never washed my own hair
i'm going to stroll right in there like
she owns the joint it's just
like when you see politicians being
hypocritical like that lady in
chicago the mayor of chicago she's like
you know
talking up these people in these
peaceful protests and
everything's fine but then they tried
protesting on her block she set up
[ __ ] armed guards
she said made a mandate you can't i'm
not a mandate
she just said you can't protest on her
street right
i have a right to protect my own safety
like [ __ ] that's what everybody's
trying to do
right that's what we're into that's what
we're doing that's what we're doing
but that's what people feel when they
get into a position of power that's the
problem with power
that's the problem with whether it's
garcetti or newsom or anybody dictating
any of these rules
when someone gets into a position of
power it's [ __ ] intoxicating
the ability to tell people you can't
work right shut it down
you know start it up shut it down like
it's intoxicating
and once you have some power boy it's
very difficult to give that power up i
i anticipate that even if they figure
out a
real cure for coronavirus i anticipate
lockdowns now for flu
i think there's going to be lockdowns
for all sorts of diseases that kill a
certain amount of people
you could you could you might be my
might be wrong
but you could see it happening you could
see it happening because they've set a
precedent for them
having the ability to dictate whether or
not people work and whether or not
people are allowed to move freely and do
whatever they want
because that's what happens when people
have power it's a [ __ ] dangerous
intoxicant
well i believe you're right about that
uh that it's a
it's a it's
dizzying uh how sexy power is
and how sexy you feel when you have it
and uh
in it but i don't think you know
i i think we find a i think we find a
vaccine we move on
or the aliens land i've been thinking
the aliens are coming
you know i was talking to a buddy of
mine the other day
another billionaire i got a few
billionaire buddies and now you
i know how to move i do i know really i
think i'm sucking up
for a reason they'll tell you in advance
with what's about to happen well
uh and uh well well this one
this guy a particular guy is uh uh
really really really smart and uh he has
no doubt in his
mind whatsoever that uh aliens are
uh dancing among us and uh i think he's
right past me you know
little baby cigars ron white i love
those things though why
are the dark ones are there different
colors well there's this one
oh that's not a cigar i know what the
[ __ ] that is that's a cdb
that we were talking about earlier give
me some of that light
thank you sir yeah i'm convinced
i'm 100 convinced i used to be uh
sixty percent and you're up to a hundred
yeah i talked to commander framer david
fraser
one time in my life i could do uh 75
push-ups and i'm down to three
you get back up to 75. no i'll show you
how all right
you got nothing else to do
i've talked to people that have seen
them i talked to this one guy who was a
pilot in the
is he the air force and navy navy pilot
i believe commander fravor was in the
navy
and um he encountered this thing that
they they call the the tic tac ufo
this is a an object that they tracked on
radar that went from sixty thousand feet
to one foot above sea level in less than
a second
they don't know how fast it did it
because it was literally a blip in the
radar it went from sixty thousand feet
down to one feet
they have no idea how fast it moved they
have no idea how it did it
it shows no signs of propulsion there's
no heat no exhaust
signature there's nothing that that has
any indication that it's acting in any
way
like in any propulsion system that we've
ever observed before right
yeah yeah john was telling me to to
watch it
uh a show called close that's it jamie
just nailed it whatever it was you just
found it
you just did it oh it's back again
there's a little uh folks if you hear
there's a little um
there's a little strange audio hum that
jamie's trying to track down i think
it's aliens
we'll get this worked out yeah we'll get
it worked out i don't think anybody's
going to care
they might i don't think so so you
you if i had to give you a percentage of
whether or not aliens are real what's
the percentage for you
um 81.
that's a good number yeah 81.3 that's
likely yeah
likely i mean how could it not be you
know
how could it not be uh uh
i i you know i really don't even it was
kind of odd that he and i were talking
about it but he has a
really nice plane and he lives in malibu
and austin
and so every time he moves from one city
to the other it happens to fit my
schedule exactly right
so i'm like that's weird i was going to
beverly hills today
how about i hop on the plane run i'm on
it by myself come on let's go
and uh nice so uh
when he pops back down to austin even if
just for a couple of days you know i hop
on and i really enjoy this guy's mind
and i consider him a mentor in business
and life i know
you're talking about john paul uh de
georia and uh
but he just started talking about it i
hear nothing but good things about that
guy god he's the best i hear he's a
fascinating dude
oh yeah yeah you you know if he would do
your podcast
you think he'd do it i think he would i
would love to have him on he
you know he's a guy that started selling
shampoo out of the trunk of his car
you know and uh and sold patron
i think last year for 5.1 billion
dollars and still
owns 60 60 other companies
including paul mitchell which you
started here's the thing at what point
do you stop working
when you're that guy never never he
never wants to stop he never considers
stopping
i was so shocked when he sold patron uh
because i just didn't think he ever
would you know because he doesn't need
to sell it
and uh but for whatever reason he did
and uh and in fact i said something that
made him laugh really hard because he
told me about it he called me and told
me that's how i sold it to bacardi
for 5.1 billion and i said well that
sounds like a lot of money but it sounds
like more money when you realize the 0.1
is 100 million dollars
that's a that's like the biggest point
one there is right
there is no 0.1 trillion that doesn't
even exist
it's a 0.1 billion is 100 million but he
said that uh to
watch him watch a show which i never
watched because i i think he got an
advanced copy of it which was
close encounters of the fifth kind is
what it's called and uh
i looked it up and it was it was coming
on something but it hadn't been on yet
so i think he just got an advanced copy
of it
and he said that it'll it'll take every
single doubt out of your mind that's
ever been there
wait a minute isn't that that's a
stephen grier movie uh
no that's close encounters are the third
kind no no that's steven spielberg oh
yeah okay steve
stevenson steven greer is the guy we had
on the podcast before oh that wrote
yeah he's a no he's a ufologist
air quotes okay sideways face right
skeptical hippo phase right blink
monocle
um um there's a lot of [ __ ] in that
ufo world
there's a lot of people that are making
documentaries and a lot of people that
are
there's a real good one though about bob
lazar
called the bob lazar ufos in area 51 i
think that's
exactly the title of it but it's by my
friend jeremy corbell
and uh it's about this guy was a
physicist who worked at uh
area s4 in the nevada desert right um
back engineering this craft that the
government had recovered
and immediately upon working there
realized like what in the [ __ ] is this
like right away i knew that this was no
technology that we had currently
available i mean this guy was a physical
he was a physicist a nuclear physicist
at los alamos labs
right worked on weapon systems right
yeah and widow and
got there and was like what are you guys
doing like what
what is this and they were basically
explaining like these are
recovered ufos and one of them
apparently according to him was very old
and it was from some sort of an
archaeological dig that they found
and the propulsion system that these
things used was
that they used this element called
element 115
that wasn't even proven to actually
exist
until i think it was 2013
they uh proved that it exists in a
particle collider
but this guy was talking about in 1989
and he said that they had a stable
supply is that your phone that keeps
doing that i'm sorry that's all right
it's weird maybe maybe that's the whole
problem that's the ufos
the um but this documentary is
fascinating because
the propulsion system that he's
describing is exactly the same
that commander fravor had described in
the tick tock ufo that they found
off of you just gotta shut it so it
doesn't make noise i just turned it off
did you
the nobody needs me they do i need i'm
irrelevant dude
i'm not irrelevant yeah no no no no no
stop saying that
anyway the um the propulsion system that
he described in 1989
is exactly the same propulsion system
that they witnessed
this tick-tock ufo using in 2007 or
whatever it was that david fravor had
seen this thing off the coast of san
diego
so what those people that
saw these crafts um that were monitoring
them in the military they were saying
they see these like every few months
they see these things they don't know
what the [ __ ] they are they don't know
what to do they scramble jets to go
watch them
they actively block their tracking
systems
and then they disappear faster than you
can look at it just
just take off they have no idea what
they are they don't know where they're
from they don't know what they're doing
and then the pentagon recently has come
forth
and released these statements and one of
them being that they've recovered crafts
that are
not of this world 86.6
i'm up to 86.6 past that later
my little cigarillo went out oh no i
dropped some
dirty tobacco juice in this [ __ ]
thing
i'm gonna scoop that bad boy out of
there i'm gonna keep drinking
um but i'm in dude i'm not like 95
you're down from 100 and i'm up to 86.
that's i listened to my own [ __ ] and
i grew up good stop
stop you're about i'm gonna drink this
with the ashes i don't give a [ __ ] [ __ ]
i gotta turn my phone back on because i
gotta show you
uh will you guys show me the ufos no the
pig
the pig whitney cummings pig whitney
cummings bang
i mean i'm not there's no way you could
possibly there it is it's right there
kapow there it is yeah that's it that's
whitney cummings pig so
she was the first person to explain to
me those miniature pigs yeah not real no
right yeah that's proof right there
right yeah how little is that pig well
they think they're miniature pigs
because they starve them
so people buy this little tiny pig they
go oh this is a miniature it's a teacup
pig and like oh great
who wouldn't want that you know yeah
just feed it right and it grows to be
you know alex ramundo bought three of
them and they they
he did he lived up in palmdale and
he eventually they just got out and then
every once in a while he'd see him now
they have tusks and they weigh 450
pounds and
you know they're run so this place do
they recognize that
let's finish the uh story we were on
which story the ufo park yeah yeah yeah
oh it won't go back into the pigs the
bob lazar documentary is a must-see
i'm directing you you should see it no
direct away i love you do whatever you
want
um but the bob lazar documentary is a
must-see if you're if you're curious and
on the fence about ufos and i had that
guy in here i talked to him he gave one
of the first interviews that he's given
in
a long [ __ ] time and i i picked his
brain for hours
i'll go back and listen to it he he
didn't seem like a [ __ ] artist to me
he there's there's some weird parts of
it but there's always going to be weird
parts when you're talking about
literally back engineering something
that someone from another planet
invented and using some technology that
we don't understand and one of the
analogies that he had was imagine if you
brought a nuclear reactor
to the 1400s and introduced it to them
which 1400s is nothing 600 years ago
right in terms of the age of the
universe it's a [ __ ] not even a blink
of an eye
i think we could just go back to 1800s
1800s
we're pretty surprised about a new cure
let's go to 1936.
yeah nuclear reactor that was his um
his intelligence i get it like this
technology is
it is technology it's clear that they
figured out how to manipulate this
element
and use it to to bend gravity
and that's the propulsion system instead
of using something that pushes
like a fire that pushes against you know
the wind and pushes you in a certain
direction
or a propeller that pulls you into a
certain direction instead of that
it bends gravity and the way he
described it's like if you put a
massively heavy bowling ball in the
center of a bed
right and just sunk everything into the
bed that's basically
like a very crude description of what
this
element does and with their this reactor
that they have on these spaceships
that it literally bends gravity around
and allows you to just
instantaneously jettison that that ship
into uh another position and say stop
joe i'm getting the bloodletting
draining my blood into a bowl to cure
something that i think i've got
what'd you say again yeah
um i think they've been here forever i
think they've been coming down here
and observing us and and waiting and it
also coincides with uh
there's a giant jump in sightings right
after the manhattan project
right so right after we started blowing
up bombs they they're like hey hey
these [ __ ] monkeys are faking [ __ ]
let's go visit him again
they probably got a you know probably
got a newswire
they probably got a google news alert on
their phones
and they're like oh christ look at these
things look at these crazy monkeys what
have they done what have they done
what have they done okay 91 i'm up to 91
what are you down to
i'm down to 50 we're uh
i'm i'm worried i'm not trying to pull
you out of it i'm always worried about
things that i want to believe
if i want to believe it i'm always
skeptical right me too i don't want to
[ __ ] up your delicious tequila with
ashes
let me refresh you there fella
thank you are you going to rinse i'm
over here
oh a little rinse i mean this is the job
i've been looking for right here
made services the only reason why i
don't believe 100
all the time is because i know i want to
believe 100 so i think that i'm full of
[ __ ]
thank you sir i'm worried about my own
desire to uh believe right
because when you want to believe
something yeah you can convince yourself
of [ __ ] that's not accurate
it's tricky right like you know
many things you know i was wondering
uh uh how trump got
evangelicals to support him and then i
read the stories about falwell jr and
i'm like it all makes sense now
falwell junior was going he's afraid you
know what i
i don't see anything wrong with any of
it
and then he told that to the rest of the
guys
and then oh was i laughing so hard
you know my my parents used to take me
to see
um god who what's his name
jimmy swagger swagger yeah swagger
remember when he got busted oh yeah
and i'm like i am the straightest human
being sexually
in the world uh uh compared to these
guys and
and i just but but but when this
happened i laughed so hard because i
just started thinking about him patting
trump
on his shoulder going hey you know what
it's i get it i get it it's liberty
university
right you want freedom and i was i was
just searching for all that information
and then it got to the point where he
admitted that his wife had the affair
with a pool boy that's right out of a
magazine
that's not even true you know so but but
it is true
and he goes but i wasn't there
watching and i'm like i already
don't believe you i already don't
believe someone says my wife had an
affair
but i wasn't there watching i'm like
wait what
what was that what the [ __ ] just
happened
what would you say you weren't there
watching okay
i whatever i did not [ __ ] that guy's pig
that didn't do it right why didn't
why why'd you bring it up yeah what are
you talking about man
where's that where's that from i already
don't believe i think they're all freaks
yeah
i mean all the evangelicals that make
all that money
there's no way power yeah power yeah
right way they just stop
at the money i used to do stand-up
comedy in this in the sheraton sand key
hotel in clearwater florida which is the
same hotel
where jessica hahn uh [ __ ]
jimmy baker yeah in the in the uh
presidential suite up there
oh man and uh you know and he was a it's
the same story right
it's always the same story and then
kennison ended up [ __ ] her yes
around comes around but she was on ken
is kennison and her were on stern
together i think she called in when
kennison was there and she was calling
him [ __ ] loser he's like you're a
[ __ ]
right yeah i remember terrible i
remember it was so terrible but the the
fact that she went from being this lady
who
[ __ ] this famous preacher to being
like this
quasi celebrity and this is before
reality tv
we've got to remember back in those days
there was only a few of those
weird pseudo celebrities right so maybe
the beginning of reality tv
yeah in a way yeah in a way that was the
beginning well you know tammy fay
wouldn't blowing him right
probably not not anymore yeah she
probably had her to get to the dance
yes but but she lost it once she was in
she had the eyelashes
yeah it kind of stunk one day and she
got afraid of it didn't she die
from diet coke i think she's one of the
people that they go man
maybe she i think she drank like 100
diet cokes a day
like a week ago i was in what is this uh
it's like i hooked up with this girl
what does that say
jerry farwell jr allegedly caught on
tape warning pool boy
not to make wife jealous what
this is the one i thought you guys were
talking about oh yeah yeah yeah that
that handsome fella
yeah young boy apparently he would watch
the the young fella would say that uh
jerry jerry jr sit in the corner yeah
and watch but imagine if
there was a point in my life well i
would have watched her [ __ ] him if i was
bored and yeah you know you have to be
real bored but
well for that one yeah i mean you have
to be real bored
unless i mean like unless you're like
unless
you are trying to really corrupt your
wife
you're like i know what i'm gonna do i'm
gonna get some guy to [ __ ] her
in front of me and that [ __ ] can't say
[ __ ] right and now on i could do all
kinds of wild stuff like
i watched the pool guy [ __ ] you i was in
the right
arms crossed i got pictures on my cell
phone
i was watching you suck his dick like
this
if you want i mean if you really want to
corrupt someone to the point where
they got to leave you alone with all
your deviance that would be one way to
do it that's probably the best way
if you're a woman because like a one
like a woman
cheating on a man for whatever reason
seems
more scandalous than a man cheating on a
woman
in general and then on top of that
i don't know why it seems more
scandalous but it does easy joe
because it seems like men cheating
it's all dependent upon the person it's
all on the individual but it's
scandalous
because it's more scandalous because the
man's letting her
like there's more threesomes and i'm i'm
just
pulling this number out of my hat but i
think there's more threesomes that
involved the wife or the girlfriend
bringing in another woman
right then ever then a guy bringing in
another guy
right right like hey you know i love my
wife but she wants she wants
hey bob she wants you to [ __ ] her so i'm
gonna watch
that's probably way more rare probably
way
way way way more because i have multiple
friends that have had their their
girlfriend or their wives
bring home other gals it seems normal
now i had a i had a friend that would
when i went a friend whatever but the
first time i met him was playing golf
with him
and he showed me a video [ __ ] tape of
his wife getting
banged by a really attractive huge black
guy
and he and he didn't even know me and he
goes look at this you handed me the
camera that's my wife
he goes my wife and i'm like that's my
issue
all right well can i get a check please
i'm gonna have to go yeah that's a guy
who's he's establishing some very loose
boundaries
right very very loose very loose for
himself too and
for your friendship yeah i think he's
gonna go real weird with that guy he's
already showing you video of his wife
getting [ __ ]
i was thinking that he was uh trying to
rope me into this but
probably and uh and if i would have done
it
then uh he would have gotten footage of
that and then boom
he'd have liberties with me too yeah you
know
you don't know what i would have done
together right that's what i'm saying
that's probably how they do it
there's a lot of like sex is such a
weird thing in terms of like
what's acceptable to some folks is
deviant to others
and i think there's a lot of uh these
people that are uh
evangelical types in particular
especially
that probably they can't hold that
standard
there's no way right right that standard
of
piousness they're out there speaking
god's word
right they're doing it to thousands and
thousands of people and it's a powerful
position which makes women horny you
know and then you start getting these
little opportunities pop
up that would have never popped up if
you were down at the first baptist
church
of oaxaca right right then uh but now
you're the first baptist
of the world right and it's probably
kind of hot right
a woman comes up a real deeply christian
woman
jerry falwell jr i just tell you i am a
woman of god
but there's something about you that
brings a fire to my loins
next thing you know next thing you know
you're doing coke
right in a penthouse yeah with a big old
glass of red wine
pouring everywhere baby yeah
oh baby you're crushing up pills yeah
listen listen no don't sweat that donald
trump's my friend i'll call him right
now
and they were like what no donald trump
really
mar-a-lago i got a gold card look at
that gold card
why else would you be a billionaire why
else correct
man don't you want to party would be all
right i should go at the [ __ ] are you
doing you just want to be a billionaire
if your bank account's full your balls
are empty
what are you gonna what is the point
am i in the way jamie am i [ __ ] up
his camera
we're uh turning real blue for a second
oh it's the aliens
they don't like this conversation what
happens when you talk about them or the
televangelists
yeah it's a it's as soon as someone is
telling you
you know like how to live your life and
people are listening boy that gets
[ __ ] crazy
all right what you can and can't do what
god wants
right remember that uh hicks bit about
jesse helms and he's
uh how'd it go it was something about uh
that uh they were interviewing his wife
after he died and she
was talking about jesse's collection of
little shoes
and
oh well that's what's so [ __ ] up you
remember when you used to think that
pedophile cults were just some
ridiculous conspiracy theory you know
like oh hey man
there's an island and they fly people
out to the island they [ __ ] underage
girls like
that isn't really going on jeff get out
of here with this nonsense
meanwhile clinton's like well he was my
friend we flew a lot
oh that's good we flew together it's not
a big deal he's a good guy i played golf
with him once and uh
and he told me a joke it was uh or
he set it up as a story so it was pretty
good you know and he goes it was a
rapper friend that he knows and
and uh he was in a maserati dealership
and
it's all thugged out and the guy goes
are you thinking about buying one of
these cars and he goes no i'm gonna buy
one of those cars i'm thinking about
[ __ ]
yeah that's an old joke is it well then
it's old joke clinton's a hack
yeah clinton i hadn't heard it so to me
it was just clinton telling me a [ __ ] a
story with the word [ __ ] in it
so thinking about [ __ ] all right yeah
did you ever do that or do you just do
that one uh i gotta i got a few
impressions
yeah yeah but he's one of my favorite i
did i had this bit
uh that i was doing for a while i don't
have you ever saw it about uh
i had a new netflix show called
ex-presidents high on mushrooms
and uh the whole goal of the show was
just to get clinton
and that you don't want to get bush
because he would just start crying all
right
you know but but and obama probably he
knows how to do mushrooms like he'll
probably cool with you like that would
probably
be that big a deal right but but if you
can get clinton
high on mushrooms like just just get
that guy to trip balls
right he should have been a comic that's
what i think
should have been a sax player you know
should have been a comic that weiner guy
oh yeah anthony weiner yes should have
been coming full-blown dumb enough
right to become a comedian
just sending his dick out to everybody
he went to jail for sending his dick to
underage people though right right
that's what he did but how do you know
how old that person is you're sending
that big pic too
be careful you can only hope careful i
didn't know but these [ __ ]
perverts and deviants you know i see
perverts and deviants that are good
speakers i'm like man you missed the
open mic night yeah
you [ __ ] up you could have brought
this to a bigger audience yeah in the
wrong business
you're in a business where you get
chastised and
you you lose everything for being who
you are
instead of like selling out stadiums
right
instead of people laughing he [ __ ] up
bro
so you're an arena comedian
right i used to be for the great plague
no but i mean that's the you know the
size numbers you draw when you decide to
do stand up is there
coliseums and [ __ ] like that
did did you ever think that would happen
in your life i don't think it's
happening when it's happening
all right like when i'm able to ignore
well most of the time i'm high right so
when i'm getting introduced
there's a moment where i do not believe
it's real and that that moment is always
that's at comedy clubs that's at
theaters and it's most
most certainly at arenas there's a
moment where they're like ladies and
gentlemen please welcome
joe rogan and you walk into a theater in
the round and there's 15 000 people
there
all right it just does not feel real it
does not feel real it never feels
real but i know how to do it yeah right
let's go out and do it like it feels
real what's up
i've earned it what's up what's up this
makes sense
yeah this is normal this is where i live
it doesn't make sense i think when it
makes sense i'm in trouble
when it doesn't when it doesn't freak me
out
you know that's that's when i'm in
trouble yeah yeah it uh
it may you know when we were doing blue
collar i think the biggest one we did
was
a little over 20 000 at the place where
they play hockey in
in nashville and uh we'll always have
the record
or attendance there because we had the
smallest stage elton john used to hold
it but we had a smaller stage in the
middle
right so we could fill it up all the way
around it and it was
packed to the rafters with these huge tv
wow and uh and then
afterwards we go back to the lowe's
hotel
and uh and uh there's a guy there from a
magazine
and doing interviews and my hat is so
pumped up i was like
well you know oh i said some stupid [ __ ]
and
foxworthy was just regular humble sweet
foxworthy right who never makes a
mistake
in those kind of ways because that's his
nature right he doesn't get drunk enough
right
yeah i do right i get plenty drunk to
say the wrong [ __ ] thing
and uh of course so there were just some
really arrogant sounding quotes out of
that but
but how what's my head supposed to feel
like after that you know after i just
walk off stage of
with 20 000 people screaming like a
like i'm a beetle or whatever it's crazy
and uh
how do i calm down from that i don't
know how you do i don't know i've never
figured it out i just i just
shake my head and go wow is that real
that's why those rock stars died at 27.
you know
they didn't they couldn't figure that
out and it happened to them young it
didn't happen to me till i was in my
late 40s not only that it happened to
them
before it happened to anybody else
before them right there was no
rock stars before the rock stars so
before the 50s and the 60s
nobody's selling out 25 000 seats like
of course elvis died in the toilet right
filled with pills how the [ __ ] is he
supposed to manage this thing that no
one's ever had to manage before no idea
there's no blueprint
there is none for us we could look at
you know chris rock and
richard pryor and steve martin and all
these other big acts that came before us
and go
okay how'd these guys handle it can i
talk to them could i could i sit down
with louis ck can i sit down with
dave chappelle will he tell me what it
was like yeah what mistakes do you know
yeah
how do you what is it like when you walk
out it's set with booby traps and i
stepped in every one of them
i mean it was like i was trying to hit
them all i was like clunk
clunk clunk really are they everywhere i
put a foot
block it's fun when you do it with other
people
chapelle and i did a bunch of gigs and
we were supposed to do a bunch more
until the covid hit but um
we we broke the record of the tacoma
dome it was 25 000 people
you just said that to be my number of 20
000. i just
had it in my pocket right and here
you're like i got this i'm gonna throw
it on him a dj
and you know right he's like the whole
thing is so crazy the lights are
spinning around and everything
and there's a there's a thing that you
feel like first of all you like
and dave said to me right right before
he went on stage like we were hanging
out in the back and he's like
not a lot of [ __ ] get to do
this right he was right dude
that was the way he said it was like
like man like yeah
and dave like me gets [ __ ] up before
shows
right he's like uh i like hanging out
with other dudes to get really high
before shows
because there's something about that
wild ride i akin it to
i liking it to skiing downhill when
you're going too fast
right you know you're in trouble but you
can still do it yeah
you make it you land at the end shhh
you're like
whoa that was dangerous because i really
didn't have control of that
at one point in my comedy career my goal
was to be smoking a joint outside that
door take a big hit
ladies and gentlemen rod white blow the
hit out in their face
hey
at one point in time and then you did it
so many times it's like all right
yeah it's a fun way to do comedy this
just uh
the the most fun thing about comedy is
not just doing comedy but doing comedy
with other people that are also enjoying
doing comedy
that's why the [ __ ] store is so great
right i know that's why we have to
recreate that here my friend
well you know but you're moving it out
to a [ __ ] ranch though
do we all get drunk do we all get to
live on the ranch you want to
i'll set that up that'd be great i will
absolutely be interested in that
we all move out to the ranch and i'll
set up barbecue
chunks of property on the lance just for
comics how about
every comic every comic that's like a
legit headliner gets like a two acre
plot of land on the ranch
you got a nice yard you do whatever you
want build a house for you
do we got it come on dude we got to do
you don't have to [ __ ] anybody
but you gotta [ __ ] my wife and i'm gonna
film it
i gotta tell you i just met her and i'm
in
she's hot oh god i had no idea i mean i
figured she was
but i'd never seen a picture of her or
anything my favorite person she's so
beautiful
nice lady got a cool personality and
yeah but yeah you could watch
i wouldn't i wouldn't care who saw that
bring in the pool boy
who's got the camera yeah i
i i don't really want to have a cult on
a ranch but um
but i do think it would be fun to have a
comedy club out there you know there's
this really cool building
it's not too far from your house and
it's a you know you ever
i wish i wish i knew the titles or some
of this stuff but
it was a cult and they built a theater
right over here right next to uh right
next to
travis you know where we went to see
monty montgomery that night didn't you
go with us over there to play that
theater
the little 350 seat i should just
explain to people that are just
listening
sometimes he asks questions to his son
marshall who's in the room
right so it's like woody who your uncle
like what are you saying
right now he's my memory here it is
jamie's got it one world theater yeah
oh [ __ ] the it's uh this guy was a cult
figure and he built this for him to
dance
look at him look at the dude oh look
oh my god of course yeah so this is over
by your house
and it seats about 350 people i did a
show there the other night
how many people look there it is right
there 350. i think so it doesn't look
like 350 there
that's perfect uh that's the perfect
size for a comedy club yeah it is
was that guy dead uh hit well the cult
dissolved and now they do occasional
shows in it
and uh is the guy still alive click on
him john i don't know
click on him down there the lower right
hand corner the bottom picture that's
him
no below it below it below that the one
below that
below that right there that one that's
him that's a cult guy
yeah guarantee yeah there he is yeah
there's something on netflix now that i
watch
he just looks full of [ __ ]
there's like there's a certain fake
spiritual look that's like one of my
favorite looks
it looks like he would [ __ ] anybody
anybody
i always feel like with fake spiritual
women they're just trying to find
themselves i give them a free pass
right but fake spiritual dudes i'm like
you're just trying to [ __ ]
i see what you're doing you're looking
for an angle you're just trying to get
an angle on some lost women
i know what you're doing bro yeah
nice abs though huh crazy abs guy must
watch his diet yeah do a lot of sit-ups
yeah yeah but anyway that building is
right over by your house
and uh well i don't want a cult building
that seems like i thought you did and
that's why it gave me this idea
you were the one bringing up the kilt
ship i'm gonna do it the right way all
right
out on a ranch i don't know the key to a
successful cult is you have no
membership
do whatever you want you don't have to
you can leave whenever you want you
don't [ __ ] everybody's wife
and you don't take 10 of their money
that's the key what's the point the
thing they're doing it all wrong
yeah what's the point there's no point
all right the point is just stay
slightly drunk and keep moving right
that's
that's the point i would like to say
you're doing it already yeah yeah micro
dosing and slightly drunk
yeah that should be the title of your
book have you ever written a book that
new york times best seller
oh [ __ ] ron white the right to remain
silent but i didn't have the ability was
uh number one it tied for 15th place
which makes you a number one bestseller
and uh for the rest of your life that's
amazing you put it on your [ __ ]
tombstone
that's pretty amazing and uh basically
it was just
they had asked me to do it and i said no
and uh
and then they asked me again and said
for this much money i said no
i don't have time i'm not going to write
a book that's not what i do i'm doing
stand up and i'm doing well
because it was after everything was
clicking right and then they said how
about we just
copy a transcript of your show and put
that in there and then you just add a
couple stories i'm like
for how much and they said this much and
i said yeah all right let's do that so
and it i had to go on a book tour which
was a pain in the ass and signed books
but
still it was a new york times bestseller
so congratulations yeah
i'm also an honorary member of uh
harvard lampoon
are you really yeah all right what else
which was very cool
you really good at badminton or
something like that uh
i'm okay at the ping pong i used to be
good at ping pong but nothing
was tricky man yeah tricky that's a
that's a touch thing
you got to be you got to have a ping
pong table in your ping pong all the
time but i was good at 160 pounds
i doubt it at 2 uh 215 i don't think i'm
that good
i think i've lost some of my twitch i
get it it's hard on the knees too
there's a lot like tennis when i see
people playing tennis i'm like man you
only have so much meniscus
i know i did you know that's dr phil you
know i play golf with dr phil but he
plays tennis that's his game
and it keeps his knees so focused it's a
great game i love playing it
that was good too i'm out there it's
amazing how much he sounds like clinton
but
no it's a little different it's
different i know it's different
but uh but he but that tennis keeps his
knees [ __ ] up
you know because he's six foot four big
guy well he tore his shoulder apart
pickleball what is this oh yeah i've
heard of that it's they have it in
venice beach but like
it's a thing that's pop it's tennis for
old people but it's popular here in
austin apparently so you don't have to
move as much
yeah the idea yeah look how fast look at
that guys yeah yeah oh
oh it just hurt his knee too yeah
but see once you play virtual reality
games this seems like a stupid waste of
time
wow out there playing pickleball you
know you play like one of them sandbox
games you ever gone to a sandbox
you know what that is yeah it's a
virtual reality studio where you go to
like a warehouse
they strap you up with a haptic suit so
you feel when you get hit
and you put a helmet on so you're in
virtual reality you wear gloves
and you you play these [ __ ] crazy
games like all kinds of wild games like
like you're you're on a pirate ship and
the the pirate ship gets taken over by
demons and skeletons are chasing after
you
you're shooting muskets at the skeletons
here apparently yeah they do i've seen
it
i think the original one might have been
in austin i believe so but i played it
in uh woodland hills
out near uh the old the old studio and
it's a blast
oh my god it's [ __ ] awesome it's so
much fun
it's so much fun and it makes you
realize like you were around when pong
came out
remember when you had the little turn
yeah yeah we thought everything that
could be invented had been invented
yeah so this is uh this is
fast forward a little bit i don't care
about these people signing up i can't oh
you can't
oh okay we don't have all the glitches
figured out they go through this thing
you put on this this thing on your foot
and on your hands and the suit and the
headgear
and then you go into these rooms and
you're transformed into this avatar
and you play these wild [ __ ] games
and that was an awesome one the zombie
one is awesome
you're in a house and the house is
overcome by zombies and they come
falling out of the ceiling and running
towards you and you're gunning them down
but your weapon's good yeah
you can take them out yes their heads
explode it's [ __ ]
awesome it's amazing yeah you're gunning
them down
and you watch their little zombie bodies
get riddled with bullets
it's amazing but it's like when you were
when we were talking about playing pong
like when we were kids and we were first
playing that like this is incredible i'm
playing something that's on the tv
that is what i look at when i look at
these games and i say what is it going
to be like
in 50 years is it gonna be like 25 years
right five years it's going to be
[ __ ] amazing it's not going to be
pickleball five months right i didn't
get that pickleball
balls on the way out the [ __ ] door
yeah it's going to be awesome it's going
to be spaceships and
now you're going to be hanging out with
bob lazar because we played paintball
uh you know which stings right yeah
that's that actually hurts
yeah paintballs but it's also fun as
[ __ ] uh but but this looks like this is
another version of that in air
conditioning
and uh you don't have to
feel the pain of that paintball hitting
in the rib they have one-on-one
like sword fights you fight with each
other with uh like modern
like crazy weapons type situations and
like me
my daughter killed me she killed me in a
one-on-one combat with you
didn't you a little bit all right but it
was fun
they're fun games man you just imagine
what it's going to be like
you know doing something where you
really can't distinguish like you're
real
it's fun you're seeing it all it's wild
the video's wild you feel it
like your chest vibrates when you get
hit it's pretty cool
but imagine what it's going to be like
when you can't distinguish it between
this
in reality in reality and you get to
[ __ ] the thing you're fighting
that's gonna happen right for sure
that's next oh that's coming
the moment they could figure out how to
do that like with this elon musk neural
link where they're doing that the moment
they can figure out how to tap into your
senses
to make you really feel like you're
having sex with like
you know tara patrick in her prime and
i'm talking
all right whoa some super hot
what's up james you got to watch that
one black mirror episode we were going
to watch it that one day and i was like
you should watch this at another time
but like oh yeah they set up the
scenario where it is it's two guys
playing virtual reality
one's a guy one's a girl and they [ __ ]
each other and they end up realizing
they can [ __ ] each other
and that like causes this whole [ __ ]
chaos of problems they both have
girlfriend or wives whatever
the [ __ ] and they wind up banging each
other and they're like who
who's going to be the girl though oh boy
oh boy
oh boy that would be the real question
right if you that's the reason i want to
go on living
i want bridgette bardot and me and uh
sophia loren back in the day 66.
oh my god yeah back when ferraris had
skinny tires
the old days the old days people didn't
know anything what are you driving now
joe
i got a lot of cars a lot of different
stuff
how many i like that my you know i got
the i got the 56 corvette
oh yeah it would have been raining i was
going to drive it up here so you can see
it yeah
i have that one that's 65 that's the 65
is prettier than mine oh that's a crazy
car man
yeah that that's the car that i drive
around where i can't believe it's mine
yeah i can't believe that's really my
fault yeah when you bring that up
because you know the
the parking lot at the at the comedy
store is a [ __ ] show
but it's a [ __ ] show between all three
successful comedians who have great cars
and guys that haven't had a netflix
special yet
but as soon as they do get one they get
a car and uh right and then you got
uh you know it was never like that you
know like that place is filled with like
millions of dollars in cars now
at least it was before the lockdown yeah
right well the old days it was half the
parking lot
you know it was the the because you had
some really successful comics up there
and then some great comics that hadn't
hit it yet
yeah uh all doing shows but we were
there the other day there was a ferrari
three porsches a lamborghini i was like
this is the craziest parking lot i've
ever seen
like russell peters lamborghini truck
was there and i was like
this is madness this this i mean
it's when it was rocking you know
i mean when i say this like the old days
but it was really only seven months ago
right seven months ago rocking every
night fun as [ __ ]
it was we were in the golden years i
mean it really was as far as comedy goes
i've been there since 94.
it's never been anything like it is now
all right because the internet
that's a bunch of your podcast and
marin's podcast and all the people that
feed it
are also working there every single
night of the week
that they weren't touring and uh
you know it bred a place to go have fun
and
i think it all stems from them their
intrinsic nature was always to embrace
stand-up comedy and it didn't matter
about your insanity so if you wanted to
be crazy
come be crazy here at the at the comedy
store and smoke pot right here you have
their own bar right here yeah and you
can snort cocaine off this piano shaped
[ __ ] thing in the dressing room with
the main room it's a mirror
a mirror a little piano made out of
mirrors that was built for prior to do
blow off of
and then many people followed in his
footsteps
and uh but they've embraced that and it
made it fun and made the comics feel
important you know yeah
if you want to smoke pot at the improv
you have to go stand
on melrose avenue and smoke it in
traffic
because they don't give that yeah they
didn't care like they did it they didn't
understand it the same way they did at
the company the improv changed a little
bit over the years
well they got that new they have a new
club up there now but i haven't been
in it since it was finished yeah it's
there's something about the store where
they realize that the comedians
are why the people are there right
whereas other clubs that's why the
comics park right next to the door
and you park where the [ __ ] you can yeah
and uh because
you're gonna get something that you
didn't even pay for when you walk in
here yeah
you know you're gonna you're gonna see
rogan and cummings and
and uh all the best comics in the world
joey diaz just
rocking the [ __ ] place he has moved
to new jersey
i talked to him about it man you know he
he's one of the
guys that uh that that checks up on me
yeah
you know just to i get a call once a
month or
every month and a half or whatever from
dia just look i'll tell you
ron
and you feel like he's doing it because
he gives a [ __ ] he does you know
he does and uh yeah we were talking
about as i was like come to austin with
us you know
we gotta this is what's going on i
didn't you know if i finally known about
the ranch and the two acres
i could have at a mule can we get do we
get a meal i'll give you a meal
this is what's gonna happen joey diaz is
gonna go through one
new jersey winter you gotta realize
joey's been out there with us since 96.
he doesn't know what winter is anymore
he's going to go through one of those
shitty new jersey winners and then i'm
going to call him up in april
ready i'm going to like joe really joey
has a spotify money's burning a hole in
my pocket
come on man come on out here i'll
sponsor you let's make something happen
i got a club going on i want you to do a
residency
let's get rolling come out here and
you'll do it
yeah i hope so i hope so i might have to
come
on a really bad day i might have to fly
out there and bend the knee i'll
i'll fly up there we go okay let's do it
i'll do whatever i
can do i'm i'm accepting the fact
because there's no comedy right now i'm
accepting the fact that he went to new
jersey
but i'm only accepting it temporarily
that's it's like a big like if you
looked at my brain
like if my brain was a circle like a pie
there'd be like a
15 percent sliver get joey diaz out of
new jersey that's like 15 percent
15 it's in there man he's the
listen he is he's a big factor
in uh all this and in the store and in
my career
and in comedy and podcasting in general
he's a big factor
because he's the party like when when
joey diaz
would like and especially me and him
together
because he knows what a fan i am of his
right so
when i'm in the room with him he knows
how much i love him and he can just be
free he can be wild and he knows
that i think he's the funniest guy
that's ever lived so when he's rocking
and rolling and i'm in the room and i'm
dying laughing
i'm the best audience ever right i love
him yeah yeah i just
he's just he's a such a unique person
he's so he's so unique i don't know
anybody like him he's so wild and crazy
and his stories are so ridiculous
he's just such a crazy person but a good
person too
he's a really sorry he's he's genuinely
sweet i mean he calls to check on me who
called to check on me you know he does
that
he's amazing he's amazing i love him to
death i just i
he's got this thing he came from jersey
he wants to go back to jersey
that's good let me get that out of your
system do one winter there
that's right i'm going to be uh i'm
going to [ __ ]
be i'm going to take a picture on a
canoe like on lady bird lake
kicking back with like a margarita go
joey what are you doing you're digging
yourself out of your [ __ ] driveway
come to texas texas joey we got a club
the mo i can't do anything until i open
up the club and one
once i open up the club then i'm going
to start then i'm going to start calling
people but tim dillon he's going to come
out here
hinchcliffe wants to move out here red
bin wants to move out here we're gonna
get a bunch of them out here and once we
have a club
then i mean it's we'll put up the bat
signal and i'm just gonna
my my goal for a club is not to make any
money my goal is to break even
and have everybody paid well and just
just just like let's
establish a community and let's do a
thing
in in austin like we were doing in la
where we're basically
just working on the art and and having
an awesome place where people can come
to see
great comics [ __ ] around and work on
material and because of the podcasts and
because of us talking about on the
podcast
i think they understood what the store
was for they understood that
it was our hub right it was our our our
home
and that we all we come like with a guy
like you and a guy like me
and you like we don't necessarily work
together
you know we you work at your places and
then i work at my places and the only
time we get together is at a club where
we're working on material
because you're headlining in these big
[ __ ] places and i'm going off of
these other places and
we need a place where that's like a hub
like a home base
and that's what the store was for us but
i think this that's created because of
comics
you know that's the reason when i played
the store
or or the factory or the improv when i
played all of them
uh or the over pasadena uh ice house
i would never ever let anybody come with
me
not whatever woman i was with not any
friends that i had
i would not let anybody go with me to
those shows
because i didn't want to worry about
them i wanted to go there and be a part
of the comedy community
and uh not to be bothered by anything
else let this be my time to recharge
relax talk to people who have chosen the
same exact
path i've chosen in life and those are
rare but they're gathered
yeah right and we have access to them
and uh that's why i lived so close to
there you know i lived a
mile and a half i guess from if i didn't
have kids i'd live right next door to
that place
right well you you could have had
another room you know
so that and that's what was so precious
and drawing you know
to me about it is that i got to go talk
stand-up comedy
tell jokes laugh so hard i couldn't
breathe
just be around comics yeah just didn't
uh
and uh you know i always kept it to
myself you know that was always my thing
yeah you know you're not not me bringing
people to see me or
my manager [ __ ] you dude don't know you
come see me at a big show when i'm not
trying
new [ __ ] you know yeah yeah i know
because if i'm eating it on stage and
and i have a friend in the audience you
know they feel horrible
i don't you know it's not me that feels
bad it's them
and i feel bad for them feeling bad i'm
like sorry you know [ __ ] i knew it
i knew it wasn't going to work i've had
the same manager since i was an open
miker
wow yeah my manager found me
in boston in 1990
god i wanna say 91. yeah i was basically
just
just scratching out a living like i
would get a few paid gigs but i was
basically a beginner
you know i'd get paid gigs every now and
again but i wasn't
were you still shooting pool for money
no i started
doing that after i tore my acl i hurt my
knee
and i had to rehab my knee and i had to
get knee surgery and
i was hanging out with my friend john
and we would go to uh this executive
billiards in white plains new york
because i'd moved to new york to do
stand-up because i met my manager in
boston he flew me out to new york and
or or took brought me out to new york
and i lived there for
from then on and uh i would go to this
pool hall and i started seeing it was a
i got just
stumbled into it just blind luck it was
a pool hall where there was a lot of
gambling
like high stakes game i saw 10 000 pool
games wow how fun
just wild wild [ __ ] people gambling and
betting money and yelling and all the
everyone it was
back in the day when you could smoke so
like the whole place is filled with
smoke
and it was like a different kind of
deviance
that was real similar to the deviance
that i had experienced with comics
and also the deviants that i experienced
with fighters because i had you know i'd
grew up in
in martial arts i grew up around
fighters and they were
a different kind of deviant
and then then i'm around these pool hall
deviants
then i realized there's there's there's
a bunch of different
clusters of people that didn't accept
the society standards they do like i
don't want to live like that
i don't want to do what these people are
asking me to do i want to i want to live
in a
in a free way you know i want to be
vagabonds i met a lot of homeless people
that i became friends with you know i
got homeless guys would sleep on my
couch in my apartment like
guys who were just pool hustlers they
would come home they didn't have
anywhere to stay they would sleep
underneath the tables at chelsea
billiards in new york
because it was a 24 hours so when your
manager found you what were you doing
i was driving limos i had uh
i'd quit fighting by then and i had quit
even teaching
because i was teaching at boston
university i had a taught a accredited
class in taekwondo at boston university
and uh i uh that was that was
that was when i won the u.s open i had
one a bunch of different
like like national and regional
taekwondo
tournaments and i was basically talking
with no instructor
and fighting and i was trying to make
the olympic team but uh
along the way i started kickboxing and i
realized that taekwondo had all these
[ __ ] holes in it and then i realized
that uh kickboxing was giving me brain
damage
so sparring a lot and then my i was
getting a lot of headaches and i was
like
i think i might be wrecking my brain and
then i quit doing stand-up or
quit fighting rather and i started doing
stand-up and i took on all these other
jobs
because i didn't want to short i didn't
want to shortchange my students
so i stopped teaching because i wasn't
in i just wasn't into it like i was
before i was obsessed with stand-up
so i quit my school i quit teaching at
bu
i uh and i was driving limos and i was
working for a private investigator i was
driving him around he lost his license
in a dui
this to this day one of the funniest
people i've ever met dynamite [ __ ]
dave dolan is one of the funniest
[ __ ] dudes i ever met in my life
he goes smoking joe it's dynamite
[ __ ] dave dolan
he remained my friend till the day he
died he he died a few years back
of cancer unfortunately but he remained
my friend to the date well actually he
had
he had a bunch of medical issues he had
a stroke a lot of [ __ ] went bad
but um great dude but
remained friends with him to the day he
died um but uh
he was literally one of the funniest
people i've ever met that never never
did stand up
and what's funny is his cousin
was bill downes who was one of the
owners of the comedy connection
and so just randomly i i [ __ ] took
i uh answered an ad you know we're
talking about 1988.
i answered an ad in the newspaper
someone was looking for an assistant for
a private investigator
and i was like whoa that's a good job
i'll be insistent to a private
investigator that sounds exciting
but really he needed a driver because he
lost his license on a dui
so i was uh driving dynamite [ __ ]
dave dolan around
and uh we would catch people mostly it
was mostly insurance scams
mostly people that were uh you know like
they were getting disability insurance
and they were still working on the side
we catch them doing that
but occasionally it was like some guy
wanted there was one one guy that dave
was following around
one guy who's uh his he had this
wife that just kept [ __ ] this
bodybuilder and uh
he would dave would get pictures of this
guy plowing this girl
and the guy was like okay well keep
following her he's like hey you sick
[ __ ] he goes
i gave you the pictures he goes i'm i'm
not [ __ ]
he goes this guy wants pictures he wants
the pictures
he's asking me to keep following i got
pictures
of this guy [ __ ] your wife we're done
we're done buddy you had to meet the guy
i mean he was such a boston like an
irish
boston character and he was uh
and he's a private investigator never
wanted to do anything else he loved it
loved it loved catching people yeah yeah
there was a guy in my golf club in
atlanta that was a private investigator
and and our uh
our assistant pro ended up going to work
for him
this uh we had these two two uh two
really big guys both named uh
was it jason they were the two jasons
and uh one of them ended up being
colt ford uh you know who that is
colt ford yeah that sounds like a
character tom selleck i know
it's uh he was a country rapper
and uh and when he i i'm
i'm he's teaching me how to hit there he
is cold
called forward look at him and
he he looks like holly joe prater yeah
he told me
we're hitting balls and uh he had a pga
tour card for eight years
he's an amazing girl really yep damn
and uh he uh he and his show
is fantastic and people love it get an
affliction shirt on
uh right there's a few pictures of me
out there with those yeah
it's very unfortunate back in the day
but uh
but i'm hitting balls he's working on my
game and he goes i'm really a rapper and
i was like can i get a check
one of those other i have a lot of can i
get a check please
in my life and never really spoke to him
again
on a serious level but i was gonna do
the tonight show
and uh man i knew that uh
oh uh god damn i can't believe it i
can't think of his name my brain's been
just skipping
so bad today um but anyway
who was it that was on that show with uh
one of the biggest rappers uh
kid rock no no no no no no no no no
black guy been around forever
cornrows old dirty bastard no
[ __ ] cornrows been around jamie
yeah i'm uh i'm looking all over the
place you follow black twitter
well i could i could no more famous than
you can even imagine i can't remember
that now i cannot find the i don't know
more famous than lil wayne yeah jesus
yeah
uh kendrick's snoop dogg's stupid oh
you're right
jesus christ you couldn't remember snoop
dogg [ __ ] i know
holy [ __ ] you know what i thought it was
like something obscure
no no no i told you it wasn't i said
famous more famous than you can imagine
snoop dogg well that's about as famous
as you can imagine
so uh he he gave me a cd and he said
could you just give this to snoop dogg
and i was like no
i put it in my pocket and i didn't of
course and uh
but my wife at the time uh it was she
was a
4.7 million uh wife
said it's really good actually listened
to it i never did and i'm like and the
next time i see him he's on the cover of
pole star magazine
and i'm like really and uh so
he would tour with these big country
acts because he could teach him how to
play golf
and the crowds loved his [ __ ] country
rap and then a lot of these guys started
implementing that
in their songs and it was all because of
him
and and then he wrote some huge hits for
other artists
that had a rap country background to him
well he
he created it and he ended up making a
lot of money and uh
but he was the the pro why was i telling
you the story to begin with
um rapper rapper um
golf no no we had passed through there's
no way you could figure it out if i
can't figure it out because i was the
one going there
dynamite [ __ ] dave dolan no yeah
right
uh private investigator private
investigator right
so but it was the other jason that was
the private investigator there was two
so
okay but one of them ended up in a
really you know
really good sized country act that made
a lot of money in publishing
and that was him and he was my assistant
pro he still plays in all the
uh pebble beach at t stuff with uh with
larry the cape that's pretty wild
some would be that good yeah no he was
apparently i didn't give it a chance you
know and
even to this day i've never really got
one of those games where
you can be like ranked number 20th
and be a multi-multi-millionaire oh yeah
ridiculous yeah
right just bawling out of control most
people don't even know who you are yeah
eastlake's going on today
so the big uh the guy that wins this
week
that the the prize purse is 15 million
where's that at east lake in atlanta
georgia oh okay i don't know
like i know well i'm saying it like i'm
just telling you
you know yeah east lake well you know
okay well
i uh okay i'll give you that you don't
know
you don't know i don't know anything i'm
a professional sports commentator that's
one of my side gigs
and i don't even know the rules to most
sports yeah that you know that's the
weird thing is that uh
people don't people just think of you as
famous i mean my son
was a huge fear factor fan the first and
you came back and did fearful
we're just talking about it and then uh
but a lot of people don't know you do
the other thing
right the oh the guy from man oh the guy
but
most people i would venture to say don't
know you do stand up
more than they know you do other things
i just don't want your most famous
friends
you're right the podcast is probably the
most famous thing i'm affordable
of course of course now because it's
gotten to this weird place but
yeah it's uh i do a lot of [ __ ] but i
tell people they're like is easy good
and like rogan and as a comic
because i only see you as a comic i
don't see you as
the voice of him hey i don't see you as
anything but a comedian
uh you know because that's what i watch
you do you know i'll watch a fight you
know and love it if you're commenting
if you're not it's not that interesting
and we were talking about that earlier
you know if rogan doesn't say it it's
not worth saying you know didn't he get
heard
in maa you know mixed martial mma i
don't know
i know where he said i'm telling you i
just don't know that much about it like
you don't know much about golf i don't
know anything about
all i know about joe the comic i watched
go on stage at the
at the store and just ripped a gut out
of these crowds
and it's so much fun to watch that i
don't really think about the rest of it
now like i said when the first time i
did your podcast i had no idea
well i i like doing a lot of different
things i don't think i'd be the same
person if i
i think i have a unique mental illness
that i i need to
be constantly stimulated with different
challenging things and if i'm not
then i make problems for myself you know
then addictions and
weirdness and i'm the person that needs
to
i need to have challenges all the time i
need puzzles
and you have things to solve i need to
have stuff to do yeah that's my unique
mental illness
like so when someone says like why do
you do so many things like because i
like being happy i like being sane
like if i if i don't i just figured it
out
over time in my life that if i don't
have things that challenge me
like if i don't get up early and work
out if i don't do something that's hard
to do
i'm not the guy i can't sit around yeah
see now that [ __ ] bothers me
i can wake up with nothing to do every
day
that's why i've settled into this
retirement i got to tell you i have not
hated the last six months of my life
when i had nothing to do at all not even
thinking this is the first thing
i had scheduled to do in a half a year
and i would and i was a little resentful
of it this morning it was raining and
i'm like i got to go do something
you know i got to go do something that's
the first time i made a commitment so if
i tell you i'll do it of course i'll do
it right i'll get there early
uh days we're here yeah great days early
and uh all week
but uh but but outside of that i've
enjoyed
this time off but i'm also older you
know i'm older and i've
you know uh uh you know i'm at a
retiring age
you know that that i've kind of settled
into it going this is not that bad
my wife taught me how to go on vacations
i wasn't good at it
yeah i needed i needed to learn how to
just accept the fact that i was
just not going to do anything and just
have fun and be on the beach and just
drink
and just relax and just swim and do
whatever the [ __ ]
you do at on beaches but i've gotten
good at it apparently i'm
better at it than you you know
i'm better at it now i'm a beginner yeah
i used to think of it as like
i see some pictures of you and mcgraw
out in uh
cabo with no shirts on going what the
[ __ ] going on here yeah you know
having fun
yeah well you know what i learned i
learned how to relax
you get sometimes you you think you i
used to think
that if i took time off i was losing
progress this is how psycho i am yeah
i'm like i'm losing
i'm losing i'm going to get i'm going to
get out of shape
my martial arts is going to slip my
comedy's going to slip i'm
um all i'm not going to be doing
podcasts that's going to slip
i had this sickness that way then i
realized
that as a healthy per the happier and
the healthier i
am as a person the better i am at all
those other things
so the more time i'm hanging out and
just having fun
if i can do that and just recharge then
when i come back i'm better
so every time i've come back from a
vacation i've been more enthusiastic
when i'm more enthusiastic i'm always
better at everything i do because
there's more
there's more positive energy more
appreciation you know
right so that's how i look at it so i i
haven't
i haven't hated this time off i don't
like what's going on with the country i
hate what's going on with the country i
i wish i missed the days when people
could just disagree yeah
i mean that's the truth isn't that the
truth we can all go privately into a
voting booth vote for who we
vote for and the next day we wake up and
see who's president
you know no fight was necessary we all
did what we were
put here to do which was to to to go
vote and
and after that you just accept it and
and go on change what you can if you can
if
you can't just [ __ ] go on with it i
haven't hated it either
uh but also like you i'm probably a
little
further along and laughed at uh then i'm
like you know i don't
really feel like i did so much of it
maybe that was enough maybe it was well
but if you're gonna build the [ __ ]
ranch and i get
two acres and a mule and a [ __ ]
four acres all right two mules four
acres
you heard it write it down everybody
write it down four acres
whatever you want whatever you want
we'll make it happen i want a plow with
a seat on it
that's what i want i'm gonna plow with
the seat that's what i want
the idea is just to do something crazy
and have fun and i already done that by
moving out here
and then just packing up that was a
bizarre move dude
that was a bizarre move i you know it's
uh
i like bizarre moves right don't you
don't let uh
don't let joe think you can't still
surprise you you know i i like doing
things you're not supposed to do i like
doing like i like doing things like this
like just [ __ ] pack up the whole
thing and doing it right when we're
moving to spotify
right so it's this big crazy deal and
then there's all this controversy behind
that looks like a tax dodge and uh
it's a little bit of that for sure i
don't i definitely don't like paying
that much in taxes i can't uh i can't
tell you
how surprised and thrilled i was to hear
you were gonna move to austin and uh and
be my neighbor because i'm i'm out of uh
i'm out of l.a i'm selling the house and
yeah
and uh beverly hills and and i'm like oh
good this is gonna work out fine
we're gonna have fun out here man we can
have a lot of fun out here i really
think so
i like i like your vision of the of the
austin comedy scene to come
and you know what there's also a lot of
really good stand-up comics in austin
for sure
always have that and uh they're they
flourish and these open mic
nights and uh i know that they're
listening to this conversation right now
going
i want to help them i want to i want to
get my five years in and get my acres
and
yeah i just well
i really do i want to help them i want
to help them the way i've i've tried to
help
a lot of up-and-coming comics in la and
get them on the podcast
promote them and the idea is if we open
up a club
when we open up a club i should say is
to have these local guys come in
pump them up let people know let people
know there's a real scene here
there you know yeah and and help them
and help them help them flourish
and help comic not just austin comics
but everywhere
you know bring them into this place and
have this be a hub the only reason why
la's a hub
is because of a the comedy store and b
hollywood
and i came to hollywood because i had a
tv deal
but really what i wanted was to be at
the store that was mecca to me
i had heard about it when i was in
boston but when i came to the comedy
store in 94 was a [ __ ]
i mean the comics are terrible it's like
every now and then martin lawrence show
up or damon wayans or
dom herrera or dice clay but for the
most part it was a lot of boat
acts it was a disaster there's a lot of
people that just had
old terrible jokes and it was just i was
like this is the store
it was very disappointing but the
the place itself drew people it drew
people there
you knew that that was the place where
the real comics went and
they made a career out of it but the the
this world is different now like for a
comic if you get a television show it's
actually like oh you're poor bastard
like you you could have had a podcast
like you could have been okay you could
have been your own boss
right you could have i mean and now a
lot of comics are realizing they don't
even want ads anymore they always just
want to do patreon they want to just
have
have podcasts and and put them out
either for free
and have uh you know get youtube ads or
there's a lot of people trying to figure
out
what's the best way to be free but for
sure the best way to be free is
not to be connected to the hollywood
machine because the hollywood machine is
all
woke now and it's completely ridiculous
and everyone's full of [ __ ] and you
we're not actors man we're different
things right you know it's cats and dogs
living together
we're [ __ ] different things you know
we can act we can do it we both have
but the reality is you're a con i'm a
stand-up comedian yes
and and i am as well and there's a lot
of us there's a lot of us
and we don't need that machine what we
need is a machine that we create
ourselves
and we did that a lot one of the reasons
why the store worked so well over the
last few years because it was fueled by
podcasts
fueled by everybody like i would tell
people hey you gotta
see this kid frank castillo he's
hilarious tony hinchcliffe this guy's
coming up joey diaz the funniest guy
ever
ron white's the baddest [ __ ]
that ever lived all these people and we
would all talk about these people and
tell these crazy stories
and then everybody would remember and
then they would come yeah we were they
were
they had international tourism to the
comedy store people were
flying in from ireland and australia
they should have been
and they should have been right because
that's how good those shows were they
would come in
on a tuesday and see one of the craziest
lineups you've ever seen in your [ __ ]
life
yeah when i was in one i mean you've got
a million of these stories
and it was it was you and louis ck
and bill burr and uh madness
and and and me and
it was just crazy
madness just [ __ ] crazy sadness in
one show
for 14 [ __ ] dollars that's madness
you know how much
it cost to put on that show out at the
ranch nothing zero yeah
we're doing it for charity at the ranch
charity i
that's the the idea is to do something
at the ranch where you build a theater
with
the concerts for charity and then have a
club in town
yeah oh satellite club a lot of these
places on sixth street are gonna go
under unfortunately
unfortunately there's a lot of places
that are going to go under because no
one can work
you know and i i would love it if they
all stayed open but some of them are not
going to be able to
and so we'll scoop one of those there's
uh yeah there's going to be uh
opportunities for you to put something
in this town that'll matter
yeah and let me make a promise to you my
brother i'll be there to support it you
know
even if i don't tour anymore i'll i'll
come do the club
isn't this exciting talking about it
really you know [ __ ] it is
[ __ ] hiding right yes that's why i'm
here i
i like exciting things all the things
i'm interested in are exciting i like
bow hunting
i like stand-up comedy i like fighting
all these things are exciting things
right like exciting things and i think i
can do something here that's exciting
i like smoking pot and watching cartoons
and doing stand-up
i like smoking pot freaking out that's
what i like to do i like getting nervous
i do my my favorite things about smoking
pot is being paranoid yep
people the thing that people get
terrified of and they run away from it's
one of my favorite parts of being high
i was i was nervous about coming and
doing this show today really yeah
why i was telling my son i said i don't
know i haven't felt nervous
i can walk on stage at the radio city
musical definitely
you know doesn't flutter my butt is what
i do and i'm ready to do it prepared to
do it and i haven't even thought about
interacting with anybody for you half a
[ __ ] year you know and
uh so you know it's your new place and
you're in town and
but uh he goes daddy's your friend he'll
pull you right on through to the other
side which of course you know
we did we already threw the other side
sorry 315.
we're beautiful it's beautiful perfect
it's wonderful
we're covid tested yeah yeah you know
the funny thing is that i took the
antibody test and then the
nose swap and uh so the antibody test
said you've never had it
but you might have it so i had to do the
no swap so i'm going over two days
but the nose swab the thing about the
antibody test is two indicators
one of them is whether or not your body
is currently fighting the virus right
so there's one is whether or not you
beat the virus and one whether you're
currently fighting the virus so you know
you're not currently fighting the virus
i feel good so according to the doctors
a very low possibility that you have it
and then we we
eliminate that with the swab right but
not before you and i hug
i don't give a [ __ ] right i take vitamin
d i'll give you a little bit we're going
to be coughing i'll give you a hug
right i've been coughing a little bit
but uh i'll just quarantine myself for a
couple weeks
eat vitamin d gummies right all right
just tell me which vitamin d you want me
to take
i just want you to take 5 000 ius a day
minimum
that's what you should be taking it's
not that much and when you eat
i have these vitamin d gummies that i
chew all the time there's like i think
you take three of them it's 5000 ius
it's not a big deal they're small
gummies it tastes good it's easy to do
is there any carbs in them because i'm
watching my car ah there's probably like
one gram of carbs no they're probably
gelatin no they're right
that's horse hoof right yeah it's it's
yeah it's it's basically
fingernails right and hair yeah it's
good for you
protein collagen yeah not bad for you
so i'm in a good relationship i really
like judge no you tell me yeah we'll go
out to you that's exciting
yeah it is that's exciting because
you're always in these train wrecks
right and you know yeah she's really uh
really really uh pretty
she's my age and uh and uh
i think that's important yeah i've al
i've never chased young women right so
much you know that
that's too much work the uh but uh
she's uh she she she came down we
started hanging out in the covered thing
but we'd seen each other before and
and uh and uh one night we go out to
eddie v's and we have this really nice
table
eddie v's is great oh i love it yeah
that's a great old-school place right
so we have this really cool table in the
bar it's these two people it's really
cool i'll show you the seat you'll take
your wife there on her on a
big night so uh and she's got a long
black dress i'm wearing a jacket and
you know we go back to the my
uh condo which is a really nice
penthouse with these gorgeous views
and uh she her son
and was a grappler and her and his her
grandson is a grappler
and she was a gymnast
and she said for whatever reason
she wanted to fight i think i can take
you down oh no
and of course that's how you break a hip
i i laughed so hard
that i couldn't she probably could have
taken me down because
she's five foot one and she's a gymnast
right she's a little bitty
and i said no i could pick
i would never ever hurt you for any
reason so if you want to come beat me up
come beat me up
but if i didn't care about hurting you
i could throw you into that table
because you're little
and i'm big right right then she
attacked me
and she did she came at me shoved me
back and i mean
she a gymnast that does uneven parallel
bars
strong like a chimp like a [ __ ]
champion except she was on me
in my center leg spread [ __ ] pushing
me back
wow and i and i was like from now on i'm
only going to [ __ ] women i could kill
all i'm going to do i'm going to say
let's let's determine whether or not i
could i'm never going to do it right i
would never hurt a woman
but i would like to i understand have
the option if they went nuts and just
jumped my ass to be able to [ __ ] beat
it off and you know live
you know and provide and all those
things that a man needs to do
i got a buddy of mine who got obsessed
with jiu jitsu when he dated a girl who
was a black belt
and she they they sparred and she tapped
him easily
and he was like what the [ __ ] so he
became obsessed with it
because his girlfriend [ __ ] him up
right
right defending himself right well jiu
jitsu is one of the rare
martial arts where a woman really can
kill you like 100 percent legit
like if you you know you know what it's
the same reason i don't have a pet lion
that's i just don't need it in my house
i understand right
i don't need it in my house yeah i get
it don't take it the wrong way
ladies i'm just saying yeah all those
killer ladies out there like
[ __ ] right what's wrong with me i
thought i had them tell you
no no planning on cornering them
right but i mean i know that you could
still share and bob at my ass right you
can still wait till i fall asleep and
then i'm gonna
right lorena bobbitt was it lorraine
yeah john bobbitt and lorena bobbit she
cut off his dick
yeah cut his dick off he was sleeping
and then he stitched it back on and did
porn
right how good was that sewing job
not good it was like about how good i
would sew it up
oh really it didn't look good i didn't
see it you looked like you know what you
guys go down the rabbit hole
oh you look at the video i don't do any
of that stuff i i watch porn on my
[ __ ]
uh ipad that's all i do i don't go any
deeper than that pre-viagra porn too so
you know because it didn't look that
good to begin with
no and it never really got hard it was
just a mess
right she sliced it off and threw it on
the side of the road they had to wait a
while before they found it
and then they had to dust the dirt off
of it
darkness and uh darkness right yeah
i just don't need that in my life i
don't need it in my life either right
but
i've had it in my life i've seen a lot
of things i shouldn't have seen but i
if someone sends me a link i'm like all
right you're going in let's see
let's see what's up oh somebody was over
the house uh
no it wasn't i was at the radio station
in new york
and the guy's showing me a you got a
video of a guy [ __ ] a snake
and i'm like okay
all right can i get a check please
[ __ ] snakes
that's going to be the name of my next
mouth no
no the check the snake [ __ ] he's got a
big anaconda
wow okay i'm sorry i even said it i'm
sorry i upset it
he's he's [ __ ] a snake can you pull
that up
i can't i'm sure i could i'm just saying
let's not show it but let me just just
show you i guarantee there's many people
before him that have done
people just go down the cue hole rat
hole you know and
uh yeah they definitely do yeah and
if you can name it there's a guy who's
[ __ ] it oh yeah
blenders guys are [ __ ] blenders yeah
right
tables chairs right that's why i hate
balls anyway that doesn't matter
i'm not gonna go there i get it but
that's the problem with the internet is
you find out
you mean everybody knows someone who's a
[ __ ] [ __ ] but you don't realize how
many of them there are
until you really go online and start
searching you know i
i was sitting in uh i was having this
place worked on or i was preliminary i
was staying down to vanzant has some
people
come up comics that i've known for years
and one of them
starts telling me a story about hillary
clinton and her pedophile ring
and i'm like what and this was probably
three years ago
and uh and how the pedophiles the the
far left uh right left wing and they
there there's a pedophile thing and i'm
like what are you talking about
and it was early q anon stuff it was
those same conspiracy theories that are
coming out now
i was hearing those three years ago and
i thought it was just one person's i
mean where'd you go to learn this
behavior you know
all behaviors learned right for sure
we're all the products of our
environment
like what environment did you put
yourself in that made you think that
this is true
when you know the other day there were
four of us
playing golf and all four phones
hit an amber alert at the same second
yeah
and and everybody knew exactly what it
does we picked it up and like there's a
missing kid somewhere
that's a beautiful [ __ ] thing right
and uh but
but now there's these pedophile rings
and
tom hanks is a what the
[ __ ] i don't think the tom hanks thing
is true i think there's a lot of people
that are just really dumb and they get
involved in conspiracy theories and they
believe everything and
there's a lot of people out there that
are sowing misinformation there's a
bunch of
russian trolls and bot accounts and a
lot of chaos and
sowing seeds of doubt in our democracy
and life in general and trying to tell
you that
all the elites are [ __ ] lizard people
that are running things
behind closed doors with satan but for
sure
there's guys out there that have [ __ ]
a lot of young girls that's for sure
yeah and that's what that epstein shit's
all about and that's what's so spooky
about it was that it's prominent
politicians and
scientists and celebrities and they all
flew out to [ __ ] island
and it's real right and then when the
guy's in
custody with [ __ ] security cameras
and
the whole deal he he hangs himself in a
way that's
physically impossible yeah yeah and
everybody's like well
huh no more need for further
investigation it's unnecessary
if there was anybody else involved in
any other thing and they died in that
way we would look deeply into it
but they basically just just tried to
let it go
past in the news cycle yeah the point
where no one's thinking about it anymore
well you know the the interview that uh
prince uh
andrew wright uh yeah it was there you
see that interview when they're
interviewing him
and the reason he thought he could pull
that off is because for years he's been
royalty right so everybody around him
were just yes man so
he's got footmen and whatever and
they're all going oh exactly right sir
oh no i can't believe someone would make
these kind of accusations against you
oh that seems like perfectly normal
behavior exactly
and but turns out the news people
weren't those people at all
right and how do you not see that coming
you idiot [ __ ]
because he's an idiot [ __ ] the
only reason why he's in that position at
all is because one of his uncles
[ __ ] one of his aunts and then yeah
right blah blah blah
blah blah blah and then there you are
you mean it's a bloodline thing it's not
like an earned position
because you've really worked really hard
to get there you don't become a prince
because you've
kicked ass you're right you kicked
prince ass and uh
for years maybe you even get a phd in
princeton
no you you just became a princess for
your whole life man
no absolutely how about that prince
harry and meghan markle isn't that
crazy like it's crazy that it's on the
news feed every [ __ ] day
it's important everything they do it's
important it's important to everything
they left the castle
oh we have to go why did they do it are
they crazy but i can tell you why they
love the kingdom because
there's no way you could bring an
outsider into that world
and have them do anything oh they signed
a megawatt netflix deal
i bet they netflix what are you doing
what are you doing haven't you learned
netflix
you've made some big boo-boos stop it
netflix if you
think about making decisions like this
call me up first me no
i'm talking to netflix oh i'm gonna i'll
get them high and i'll pull them aside
and go listen this is not gonna work
you're gonna spend a lot of money
right no one's talking about buy another
ron white special
that's what i'm talking about yeah what
what these people are is like this
they're good for snippets
in the news they're good for you look at
the google newsfeed like what are they
doing
oh they're actually they're extradited
from the kingdom no one cares about them
anymore i think you're 100
wrong i think that the people
will watch this crap no matter how bad
it is if it's connected to this guy and
this woman
people will watch it and they will
continue to [ __ ] go oh my god look at
the kardashians
you know they're not a talent one in any
of those people
wait a minute did you watch her sex tape
you talking all this [ __ ] did you watch
her sex
tape no well you should have then you
wouldn't be saying she doesn't have any
talent
really was it good it's very good how
was it yeah enthusiastic
i watched that paris hilton lame little
i think i think that family all [ __ ]
aside no jokes
is the mother is very skillful in the
way she's managed them
that's what it is well something's
beating us about it because nothing
works better than this
you know i was doing a show at the
improv or at the uh
mirage and they had that little
kardashian t-shirt shop
yeah right there as you remember that
mm-hmm one of the ones you haven't even
heard of was going to be there and there
was a line
300 yards long to get into this what's
now a soap shop
and i i walk by that that's where i work
i'm there 10 weekends a year more than
anybody
and that's my place and i stay in a
villa right back there
and i and one day i walk in there i'm
just looking around the kardashian
to see what they got they got towels
with kim's likeness and stuff on it
and they they said sir you can't come in
here with the beverage
i'm like what do you think i'm gonna
spill a coke on your towel
okay i think we could probably but
anyway they made me leave and uh
they [ __ ] made me leave and quite
frankly
well it's they've figured out a way to
keep people interested and keep people
talking about them
and yeah i just got through doing this
that's how good they are
i just got through doing it yeah we're
helping them and then the mother
but but here's the thing about kim she's
done some legitimate amazing work
in getting people out of jail that were
wrongly accused
that's why i don't make fun of her
anymore except the thing i said about
her sex tape
but other than that i thought you were
saying something really nice about her
sex tape you weren't dissing it that you
were saying that i felt like that she
was go at it thank you very much but
she's really done a lot of like
legitimate good to help people get
released from prison that were wrongly
accused
well you know what the problem that i
have is sometimes i talk about things
and i don't know jack's [ __ ] about him i
just make up a
funny thing to see in my head and then
later i end up going well [ __ ] really i
didn't know she did that
me too but i did i i saw the woman that
she helped get out of uh
prison and i thought that was a yeah um
we've had a couple guys from the
innocence project on here
i love the innocence i love that series
no it's uh
it's amazing and she's a douchebag that
guy that was doing the tooth
my [ __ ] uh was that guy
it was on that he was convicting people
from tooth
oh tooth by him yeah it doesn't work but
there wasn't a bottom
imprint and then he was sending him to
prison and let the other guy that was
killing kids go free yeah
well josh dubin who's one of the guys
who's been on this podcast before he has
a uh podcast called
junk science um it's uh
about the innocence project about
wrongly convicted people because of junk
science
about like bite marks there it is
wrongful conviction junk science bite
mark evidence
and this is uh this is josh dubin who's
been on the podcast before
that guy made me cry like a baby telling
me some stories about people getting out
of jail that were wrong i wasn't
trying to make you cry but i could have
you know but i just chose not to
okay i got i took i'm taking it a
different direction threatening me
i'm not threatening you joe i'm just
saying that if i wanted to make you cry
right here in public like you were
crying that night at the
improv and i was wiping your tears off
tell me about austin where am i gonna go
i'm gonna come with you i don't know if
i could live in texas but i have to move
everything
yeah i'd have to move but it's too hard
i'll be there
i was all in dude i was always i was so
[ __ ] thrilled i'm like
how was it you heard the news coming out
of my [ __ ] voice the day i found out
that uh joe was coming to town
and i'm like and and then i write you
know what i knew jay was coming but i
didn't know he i don't know if he's
really coming because nobody i talked
him into it
somebody's nobody's selling their
property over there they're just
getting a place over here he'll sell his
property there eventually i'm like come
on man what about you are you going to
sell the place i saw my place yeah yeah
yeah i think i'm staying here i like it
a lot i felt i felt real comfortable
real quick
real quick i'm only been here a little
over a week right i [ __ ] love
right you're brand new you're new neat i
already got a studio
i'm all set up you got a badass studio i
got jet skis i think you could have
built it in an airstream
you know and saved the money that could
have right right but it's
moved it around you know i feel like um
this is a better spot for me and again
it's like practicing what i preach
i don't think we need to be connected to
that machine out there that hollywood
machine that's well
we know you don't nobody does right
because it's a bandwidth right
yeah same thing you could do it from
anywhere it's that
you could do it from anywhere but it's
also what really serves the comics
what really serves the comics is the
podcast industry the podcast industry
goes where the podcasters go
right so let's bring them all here yeah
you always have the
ability to move my number you know by
saying something on the internet which
you were always
willing to do and and uh you could see
it
and you have people coming up yeah i
heard it on the road yeah i'm like good
i'm good sometimes you're just lucky
right i'm lucky you're my friend
a lot of guys that were friends of
letterman got to do letterman all the
time because they were his friends
right whether they were that good or not
they they got to do it over and over and
over and over and over
you know i've watched a few of your
podcasts everybody was more interesting
than me
you know i used to be a comic you keep
saying that
i i used to be a comic too that's horse
[ __ ] you're a comic
you're ron [ __ ] white man don't ever
say that you need to stop saying that
once i get you up at the club come on
man you're gonna crush
you're gonna tell that story about those
that's what i'm waiting for i'm waiting
for the i'm waiting for the club
once again so we'll search that they
will come as soon as we get this mayor
out of office
just kidding as soon as we figured out a
way to open up these clients
we have a meeting under the bridge
yeah no we got a bunker we don't need to
go under the bridge we just need to get
good clubs open tests as soon as they
come up with rapid testing and some
more uh terrible therapeutics you're
right yeah you're right we'll be all
right
people want to go out man they miss it
they miss it bad i miss it
i miss sitting in a club watching other
comics
almost as much as i miss doing stand-up
i miss it everybody
and people that are just fans they just
have regular jobs that used to love date
night go out to a comedy club have a
great [ __ ] time right have a few
drinks laugh their ass off they miss it
but we're going to add bad ass barbecue
to that [ __ ] yeah
yeah you got it yeah we just got to make
weed legal here god damn it people
i know it's kind of legal all we have to
do
is continue to work in that direction
because it's the process of evolution
right i thought
i thought that texas would probably sell
uh medical marijuana before oklahoma
because they're so much more
conservative it seems
yeah but now it's flourishing like crazy
yeah
and uh did the money get out of it right
texas doesn't need the money because of
oil but
and just other things but but eventually
it's going to make sense to texas you
know it'll be laughed upon in 15 years
or 10 years or five years
as a prohibition that was so [ __ ]
stupid
like it is in california like it is in
california you can't even imagine i
remember the day that i lived in i moved
to montecito
i'm down at this head shop i want to buy
a piece i just bought this house
with a big view of the world and uh
there was a guy there with a skateboard
he was waiting it was going to open in
15 minutes
and he goes are you you got your license
you're going to get pick up some of my
herb and i'm like what
and then i spent 20 minutes going what
what has he explained to me that
marijuana was legal in california i
didn't even know it
and he goes yeah what you do is you go
down he goes where's your license it's
it's
atlanta he goes oh yeah that's okay just
go down there apply for a license
they'll give you a paper license take
that to this doctor and in one hour
you'll be back here
open that door there's 15 kind of what
what are you [ __ ] what are you
kidding me
and i walked in there and he wasn't
kidding it was
[ __ ] 15 kinds of gorgeous bud
ice cream that made you want potato
chips right i'm getting fatter for sure
and all the hash hash will all this
stuff
and i buy all of it i spent two grand
and i do i
spent two thousand dollars and i go back
up to the house i'm there by myself
and i got my new bong i'm pouring this
and this taking this hit that hit
off this eat some of this [ __ ] ice
cream which they didn't put a real
dosage on you know but i'm just [ __ ]
i'm so [ __ ] and then i start feeling
weird
right and i go wash my face and i lay in
my bed and i start going
montecito's a trap it's a trap oh the
drugs here it's going to ruin my life i
should take all that
weed and all this stuff flush it down
the toilet i'm going a bug
this is a horse and then like an hour
later i mean they're going so what else
we got in here
don't do it all because that doesn't
work and uh it's got to get past the
rough spots
right yeah but i always like to get too
[ __ ] up and come down a little bit
right
to kind of wander into a buzz that way
well when you come down a little bit you
feel real thankful you're not as [ __ ]
up as you were an hour
right yep and i hope an hour from now
yeah you know i have those feelings yes
those good feelings
good feelings of survival i think you
have to feel like you're going to die to
really appreciate being alive
right you know i've i've had some uh
really [ __ ] low spots in my life
and uh in the touring career when uh
literally i had joint custody of my son
when he was two and a half years old
and they were like okay here you go and
i'm like oh
nobody's going with me or nothing and i
just have a baby
and that's that and i'm like okay i have
a van and i
i plop marshall down in the uh in the in
the car seat next to me in the van and
go
uh okay here we go
and uh and we took off across the
[ __ ] country and going to comedy
clubs literally
i would walk up to waitresses before i
went on stage and went could you just
hold him
about 45 minutes really and uh is he out
there
being held by a waitress and while i'm
up on stage doing stand-up comedy that's
crazy
and i'll tell you the funniest thing is
he's a brilliant young man and
but uh here's how smart he is
we're at the south county funny bout and
uh
and uh he goes uh dad because every once
in a while i'd bring him on stage right
and go here's my baby get that vote
right it's an easy vote to get and uh
and uh he goes dad i i want to come to
the club tonight but i don't want to go
on stage i just want to hang out in the
green room and i said this club doesn't
have a green room and he goes oh it's a
funny bone
right and how amazing it is to put that
together
that funny bones are shitholes and they
don't have [ __ ]
green rooms right at least the one
columbus doesn't
right but none of them do there's not a
green room in the [ __ ] bunch
yeah and he realized that at two and a
half years old two and a half years
hilarious
yeah it's a funny bone he's two and a
half
oh my god that's funny but that's how he
you know that's how he's raised and i
took him down to mexico when i started
making pottery and
his mom who lives you lived in mexico
for a while right but this is before
blue collar comedy right right before
right before
what what brought you to mexico i'm
impetuous dude
um i would the the funny bone cut my pay
by a third because they realized they
could
and uh and uh and really they took away
a lot of the airfare so it was really
almost half
and and i i told them to go eat a
steaming bowl of [ __ ] and
and uh my girlfriend at the time was a
artist
sort of person and she was doing this
mosaic tile application of pottery
and then she would take it to these
fairs or whatever and sell it and she
just sell it all in two hours but the
fair is three days it took her six
months to make it
and so i thought why wouldn't you just
go to mexico and hire a bunch of women
to sit around and she orchestrates it
and they sit around and make this
pottery and then you have a bunch to
sell and
that was the whole concept and so i went
down there
and i had um i was living on a lake lbj
right up from you and i sold that house
and
and uh i had the biggest truck rider
makes pulling the biggest trailer rider
makes and i had my van that marshall and
i toured in
and the biggest trailer that they make
behind that and that was everything i
owned and we went straight down to
mcallen texas
and moved into a trailer and then we
moved
then i found a place in mexico in
reynosa mexico where abraham answer is
who's a great golfer who i love to
follow
and uh we moved into mexico
met a woman named munoz and irma
knew everybody she was like the
matriarch of the entire
subdivision there and uh there was a
tortilla factory that had been abandoned
and i rented it for 100
a month and it was a wreck and i had
eight inches of cat [ __ ] in it they went
in there and cleaned it all up and we
started [ __ ] make a pottery
and pottery pottery and uh
i remember that two of the i it may have
been
the two sons of not wasn't here but one
of the employees were
the little kids and they were marshall
was five or six and and they were
four and three or whatever and they were
fighting and marshall went out on the
front porch and went
alto and uh because that was a word he
knew and uh
but uh they didn't stop but
he still knew how to command him to stop
and uh
so we had a glorious life i spent my
evenings [ __ ] sawing tables and
building [ __ ]
and they were making pottery and i was
sweating how old were you back then
42 or three maybe and that crazy so you
had toured and you kind of like settled
into this idea that
i'm just gonna be here in mexico making
pottery yeah
yeah but you know but but foxworthy and
i had been friends for already
i met foxworth the first day i did
stand-up so so he goes why don't you
come with me
on the weekends and and open for me in
the big shows right so he'd gotten big
enough to take somebody with him and he
picked me to take with him
and uh so i would go out and make more
money
than i'd ever really made before my life
opened up for foxworthy on the weekends
and then i'd fly back
from we'd be on a private jet and then
we'd fly back
to atlanta and then i get on a plane to
houston then mcallen texas and then
drive across
and to mexico
have i ever told you the tomato story no
so my mother grows these amazing
tomatoes
that were so good the property she lived
on which was in buda which is just south
of here
was a peach tree orchard at one time in
a cattle farm
at one time but the soil produced a
tomato that you could just eat over the
sink like an
apple they were so good and clearly the
best i'd ever eaten
and boxworthy
was so in love with these tomatoes that
he would call because mother would send
him a box of tomatoes every year
when does the tomatoes come i mean use
the ripening on the vine okay
you'll get your tomatoes when you get
your tomatoes and uh
i'd been out on a run i picked up a
comedy club that wasn't a funny bone and
then a couple of fox worthy days so i
was gone for two weeks and
mother sent me the box of tomatoes
and uh all the money that i'd made i
already owed to the people that worked
for me
right and uh i didn't owe it to him but
it was coming up right i
was gone i didn't have any money and uh
so i
stopped in macau at the post office and
they bring out a big old soggy
[ __ ] box and i know what it is i know
my mother sent me the tomatoes and they
went rotten
in the [ __ ] post office while i was
out doing stand-up right
so i said ass tomatoes you know throw it
away and
and so i get in line i'm exhausted i've
been traveling all day long
literally all night and all day we'd
done a show in seattle flow back on a
private plane to atlanta to houston
hadn't woke you know just beat up
and i get over to my house and uh the
phone rings and it's my mom and
and she goes did you get the tomatoes
and i said mother i've been gone for two
weeks
and the tomatoes were rotting and she
goes at least you got the hundred
dollars
oh i get back in my car
drive back to america drive to the
[ __ ] post office
go back to the dumpster [ __ ] open the
lid
crawl in it and start rubbing through
the [ __ ] rubbish until i found that
box ripped it open and got that hundred
dollars
put it in my pocket and went back
[ __ ] home that's how much i needed a
hundred dollars
wow i dig through a dumpster to get it
and
uh i forget where we're at right before
that
um but you were in mexico and that's you
were
doing pottery yeah opening for jeff fox
yeah and then
well basically then you know the
uh blue collar comedy tour came up you
know
because the kings of comedy were doing
such huge numbers and
foxworthy was like you know why don't
you why don't we do another version of
that
you know for a different you know uh
marketplace and
and uh he told me the concept of the
four of us going out but i didn't really
know what the king's comedy were doing
you know
i wasn't playing golf with him back then
and uh
you're making pottery in mexico like a
pottery in mexico
with beautiful stuff this is
pre-internet turned out it was heavy and
fragile which is a horrible combination
that way i really hadn't thought of that
i didn't really think the whole thing
through i was like what about this
it is crazy though that it all popped
for you at 42.
well probably 40 you know 44 45 and
uh before that came out right we did it
but that was all
jeff's money right he paid me great to
do it
but it was his thing right it would have
been nothing without him ever
we couldn't have sold ticket one without
foxworthy and that and even if it was
just sting ball
it didn't work at all we tried and
but we just cut the guy making all the
money out of it and uh
give the money okay nobody shows up
so um yeah so he's i think
foxworthy is one of the most underrated
comics ever
i really do that you might be a redneck
series genius
brilliant yeah if your family tree
does not fork right
and it was all so long i mean those
jokes were so long ago but it was such a
great hook
and something that you can just do it
over and over and over and over
but there was so much to him besides
that
right and to this day you know he's just
somebody that
when i talked to him uh we were both
doing little clubs in atlanta warming up
for something else
and so we had dinner together and uh
you know i don't know eight months ago
or whatever it was and
and uh it was just glorious to sit down
and talk to somebody that was so
generous that the first day i ever did
stand up he told me i needed to put the
punch line at the end of the joke
and then i said how you do that or
whatever stupid [ __ ] voice i was
using that day and
and he sits down with me brand new comic
with a piece of paper
and a [ __ ] pen he goes all right
how's the first
joke go he writes it out himself in
longhand
and he underlines this part and this
part in this part he goes
you're what you're doing is instead of
saying this here you need to say it here
right because if you say it here you're
stepping on the lap
by doing the end of it now i can't
imagine now how you would do that wrong
or not how to do
not know how to do it but i didn't know
how to do it then and he was so generous
he just sat down and showed me i've been
doing stand-up for
four minutes and he and i had a guy that
good going
okay look at this just think amazing
just think about this if you do it here
instead of here what happens
stare at them they'll laugh and then you
can move on to the next [ __ ]
challenge wow
so that's how uh that's how much he's in
i've never heard anything but good
things about that man no there's nothing
there's nothing but good you know
a great human being uh dear dear friend
count on him for anything
he's a big time bow hunter too you know
he's a big time hunter
he uh he
he and everybody respects him as a
hunter you know he doesn't take out a
lot of deer
during the year you know he looks for
trophies and if he doesn't see him he
doesn't shoot adam
you know he doesn't old mature deer that
have passed their breed inside
yeah yeah that's what he looks for
that's how you're supposed to do it and
um
you know and i've never been into that
he's always tried to get me to go and i
would probably go with him i mean i have
no
reason not to you know except i'd have
to learn how to shoot a bow
you should come out here and we should
shoot some pigs
they have to get rid of them these wild
crazy pigs so the pigs uh yeah the pig
stones don't think about whitney's pig
put that in the back of your head so jay
and i were gonna do
uh who was the hanging judge jeff
yeah there he is what's he doing in this
video jamie i was just hunting i just
found a hunting video
he's just outdoorsman hunting something
right there
that's a nice deer it's on facebook
yeah he's out there whacking deer so
anyway jay and i were going to talk
we're talking about doing uh who was the
judge west of the pecos
here and uh
so we were talking to this director i
feel stupid for and i know his name
famous director lives right here in
bastrop uh who did
[ __ ] my brain's just not working today i
can't catch up with all of it and uh
but he owned the he he actually had also
some pigs that he put into this and he
wanted to do a reality show about the
the pig ranch and bastrop
and so
jay because he can produce anything
right he's got a great production
company and uh so
he sells it because this guy's the
director [ __ ] who's his name oh i can't
believe it
sorry give me a movie the first movie
that
uh mcconaughey was ever
guessing on this the last bit yeah
richard
bam jamie right out of the [ __ ] gate
yep he's a mentalist um
so we we pitch him the
the the judge roy bean story but jay's
there to
wrap up the deal on the pig ranch the
pig rescue
right so we
they want to go over there well now i'm
part of the [ __ ] team right i'm like
[ __ ] yeah because i want this guy to
direct this
right because if he doesn't it's a hit
and he's sold for sure he's an amazing
director
uh and we go over there and and it's
huge and it's nice too
the pigs are 800 pounds
some of them can't hardly move have
arthritis take some 30 minutes to lay
down the last
pig and uh this is a
thing no oh something different
no that's not the last pig good luck
with that there's a lot of pigs
but anyway we make our way around the
whole thing and and they have
footage because you know they have all
these cameras out of of pigs that are in
the wild
walking up to the fence going how do
they get in here
they're [ __ ] eating sandwiches and
[ __ ] laying around in the mud
and then there's people pigs outside the
gates going what the
[ __ ] is this i want in now you can't get
i wonder if you let
wild pigs in if they revert to being
like domestic pigs because if you take
domestic pigs
and they go wild like you were talking
about your friends pigs
they didn't grow up tusks yeah and they
think they were fine
yeah i don't know but anyway we make our
way into the house
with it which the the guy that runs it
is
runs a big construction company he's got
a lot of money but but his wife
uh looks like the chick from pulp
fiction that
that goes nuts that has all the
piercings and stuff and
oh yeah yeah and when i walked into that
environment i saw her
and i'm like she's set to pop
don't do it
so yeah she's about to pop her [ __ ]
weasel right
i think that's my feeling about the
whole situation
i get it and we get in the house and
they're gonna sit down and talk about
this deal
we sit down for about three seconds she
goes i'm out of here
she walks out the door slams the [ __ ]
door and i was like i saw that [ __ ]
coming i didn't tell anybody right but i
did see it [ __ ] coming
i'm like this girl's about to pop i've
seen it
i've seen it you know crazy right you've
been around crazy
and then yeah and he goes she's not
coming back
and uh i'm like yeah she didn't look
like she was coming back
she looked like she was anyway i said
i'm gonna
they said something about they need to
talk about the deal and i got a joint in
my pocket i've been dying to smoke for
[ __ ]
hours and i'm like oh yeah i'll just be
right outside here and
smoke but but before they did that there
were four pigs that lived in the house
and one of them was whitney cummings pig
and they brought whitney
cummings pig out to me and gay and i
held it and it squealed like i was
[ __ ] it
but i totally wasn't i totally wasn't i
totally wasn't
but i definitely did not watch that man
[ __ ] my wife
yeah i already don't believe you
i already don't believe you
oh that's a powerful statement oh
so anyway then there's that story brown
white let's wrap it up
we did it wrap it up we did it my
brother another beautiful podcast
thank you thanks for uh making me come
here yeah part of the reason hey you
know you
i needed to stop you from crying i'm
like i'll make some promises i'll pitch
in
you know do much do my thing i knew
there was a spot where we could be
together
yeah all right yeah i was trying to
steal you back from mcgraw
you know i'm like my two friends kind of
went off together
and i'm like oh i see a way out now it
turns out he's moving down here
he can vacation with us too well
vacation when it's legal again i got
nothing to do man come on come on
you got something to do once the branch
opens up yeah absolutely figure out what
to do with your four acres
two mules yeah i love you ron white i
love you joe rogan
all right bye everybody good night
you